Good Lord, brothers and
sisters of the universe. We're
back. We're back. Once again.
This podcast is supported by many find
sponsors. Let's get into him right quick.
Number One, first and foremost we're
brought to you by on it. On it.
O n n I t is a human
optimization website. Um, it is,
uh,
a website that has evolved and grown from
the birth of this podcast. It's sent,
essentially caused the business to form.
Um,
what it's about is selling what we
deem to be items that enhance human
performance, enhance your physical
performance, your mental performance,
enhance your, mute your mood, give
you healthy choices as far as uh,
things to put into your body and
strength and conditioning equipment.
We sell kettlebells and steel maces
and ab wheels and medicine balls,
all these different
things like weight vest,
things that really enhanced
functional strength. Um,
if you've never done kettlebells before,
it is a fantastic series of videos that
are available at [inaudible] dot com. Um,
and if you've done it a few times,
do you understand the form?
The best one is Keith Weber's
extreme kettlebell cardio workouts.
They're fantastic cause there's
a lot of kettle bell DVDs.
It'll show you like how to
do the individual exercises,
but they don't do the workout with you
and like make you keep up with them. Uh,
I just actually have been going back
and forth with Keith, Keith Weber,
so he's going to be on the podcast a in
October. I'm very excited about that.
I really want to talk to him cause his,
uh, his workout DVDs or like I said,
my favorite, if you thinking about doing
anything like this, please start slow.
If you've never worked out and you smoked
cigarettes and you're always drunk,
do me a favor,
please start slow.
Don't be dropping a fucking big 72 pound
gorilla kettle bell in your head cause
you getting crazy and you're trying to
do it all in one day. It takes time.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N n I t use the code word Rogan and save
10% off any an all supplements and a,
this just didn't, we just got
in and were drinking it now, uh,
on it caveman coffee,
this is our friend Keith Jardine and
Tate have created this company called
Caveman coffee cause they're
both fucking cave men and uh, uh,
they have a relationship with a
guy who grows coffee in Colombia.
His family grows coffee and they, they
go direct to, it's a single source, um,
a farm. So it's kind of interesting. Um,
just by happenstance because Tate is a,
takes a big coffee fanatic.
Always has been that dude ever
since we've met him. Wouldn't,
he wouldn't go anywhere without a
Venti Starbucks in his hand. You know,
he quit alcohol and drugs and went right
to coffee. That will, that happens man.
Those dudes that are on the program,
they're in like a 12 step program.
They love their coffee cause it's
gives you a little bit of a buzz,
but nobody has to get crazy and you,
so you satisfy a little bit of those
demons and keep everything cool.
You're giving yourself a little something
something, but it's not fucking you up.
So those guys love coffee.
It's very rarely see like
alcoholics anonymous dude who uh,
although you're not anonymous, if you
tell everybody sober by the way, right?
I wonder, do these people
awesome. Move on to other
things like s like sniffing markers.
Now you can't do anything like that.
You're not supposed to do anything that's,
you know,
what would be the word
for it? Twisted. You know,
anything where you're feeding some,
some more caffeine. Is that kind of,
all these guys are addicted to Red Bulls,
but that's not markers.
That's not like huffing paint. Yeah, I
guess which one is more dangerous? Oh,
without a doubt.
Hustling caught a big mess.
It's actually good for you
or about sniffing played out
and people who deny this.
Listen,
you have to read some articles on this.
It appears that coffee
has a lot of functions,
a lot of benefits. You know what it
is? It's like every fucking thing else.
You can overdo it. You can overdo it.
You can drink coffee all fucking day,
every dangerous torch,
your adrenals.
Just Jack your system or you can
have a little bit of it every day.
It has. Um, it gives you a
stimulant effect on top of that.
It's a rich in antioxidants. It's like
a lot of good things about coffee.
Believe it or not,
it's actually not bad for you.
We used to think it was bad for you.
What's bad for you is dehydration,
but if you drink coffee and you still
drink water and keep yourself in order,
just crazy bitches.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t use
the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any
end.
All supplements.
We are also brought to you by nature box
o and ms pat is eating some naturebox
right now and she can attest to
the yumminess with this product.
They're very good. Everything's
good. The whole deal.
Natural nuts to salt mango,
almond pistachios, kapow.
These are lemon pluckers but
Stassi yellows. Yeah, these, Oh,
they're mango almond bites. That's what
they are. These are fucking delicious,
but the best is Sriracha cashews.
Nothing can fuck with them.
They're all gone when you just have them.
Just send me boxes of Sriracha. Cashews.
If they're listening. Can I
have one? I have one request.
Can you order like I just want to order
four packs of the cashews but it won't
let you, they won't let you order
for yeah, like I want to be able to,
and it gives you like a stopping point
where you can only order like three extra
snacks and then like you
can only order total of,
I think it's like 10 like we'll have to
move into that but let's not focus on
the negative. I'm just saying
cause what? I used my box so fast,
I just want to order more. Yeah,
we'll order more boxes. I don't know.
I don't know what to say. I
haven't noticed that. That's,
that's fucked up though.
You should be able to order like 50 boxes
of just Sriracha. Cashews only. Yeah.
And I want it once a week and I have
it once a week and won't get the once a
week. It doesn't, unless it's
really confusing to do that.
You think they would want to add? You've
got to check this before you say it.
And you know that you can't do it.
I've tried it a million times.
They won't let you order one a week.
Yeah.
Why do I have a feeling that
we're going to find out?
It's really easy to order one a
week. It might be, but I tried. Okay.
Nature box anyway is very
good and it was really good.
Um, the, the problem is that
you can't get enough. Exactly.
Mine goes through in three days
and that's what the total addition,
she'd go to a supermarket and get actual
foods can actually be living off of
this. You can't, it's not
enough calories. You need more.
Otherwise you're go retarded Cheddar
potato fries and what your problem is when
you just, you're just not getting enough
nutrients. I just can't leave the house.
That too.
Anyway, they're delicious.
Zero Trans Fats,
zero high fructose corn syrup and a, you
could get snacks that are low in sugar,
a non Gmo and without gluten and they
shipped for free. It's good shit man.
It's really good stuff. Peanut
butter, nom nom is a really good,
do you ever have those
baked sweet potato fries?
A lot of healthy choices to a lot of
choices where you don't feel bad eating
them at all.
And it's so much better than the shit
that you're going to get from any vending
machine, period. So if you keep me at
work, it's a fantastic option. You know,
you'll always have a healthy
snacks and they deliver them to.
So if you're like Brian and you
don't like leaving the house,
he just bring them to you.
And if you go to naturebox.com right now,
you're going to get
50% off your first box.
It just go to naturebox.com/rogan so
naturebox.com/rogan and you'll get 50% off
your months. First box, stay
full, stay strong. My friends,
naturebox.com/rogan Chili lime pistachios.
Those are good too.
But I'll tell you what,
I have a grievance with
them to then cause uh,
there's a supermarket near my house,
it's house pistachios out of the shells.
And once you eat pistachios
out of the shells, you're like,
why are you giving me any stupid fucking
shells and pretending this is a big bag
of pistachios? No, this is a big
bag of shit I can't eat that.
You expect me to take out before I eat.
How about you just give me the fucking
pistachios. I have shells all over my bed.
Suck it before you. It's not,
it's overrated. Crawfish. I,
yeah, those are good. Those are delicious.
Don't get me wrong. I'll take
them over. Nothing. However,
the best option is when they're
already out of the shell.
Then you just eat the shit out of them.
You can't believe how many pistachios
you get in your fucking face.
They call some more. Yeah, they
definitely costs more, but it's just,
it's one of those things and
we've just come accustomed to,
it's stupid that you got a shell on that.
It just shells not helping anybody.
Naturebox,
they'd have a nature bucket of just these
roasters like Saracha roasted cashews.
I will, I will pay 40 bucks a
month if I get a bucket. Eddie's,
I could get Tuckey fried chicken
size buckets, nature bucket.
Anyway, naturebox.com/rogan
go there, enjoy and a last
and finally we brought to
you by stamps.com stamps.com
is another awesome way to
stay inside your house. That's what
we're promoting ladies and gentlemen.
Essentially we just want you to stay home
and consume Internet content and lose
your fucking mind.
But if you go to stamps.com and click
on the microphone and enter in the code
word j r e you will
get a $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and
up to $5 worth of free postage with
stamps.com is is a way where you
can print from your own computer,
you s postage,
the real deal.
You never have to go to a post office
again if you have your own business,
like Brian does a desk,
squad.tv where he sells all those cool
kitty cat tee shirts and now hats,
those hats, all kinds of groovy
shit. Um, hoodies, right? Yep.
Put his house up until 5:00
AM shipping these from stamps.
Yeah, he really does have a
legit job with stamps.com um,
and what they do is,
you know,
they have it so that you do
everything on your computer,
your printed up with your printer,
you slap those babies on your
boxes and you send them out.
How much easier is it then going to the
supermarket, supermarket, I mean brother
so easy. I thought I couldn't even
fit it in my car. What I have to do,
like I would have to take four trips to
the post office now I can just do it on
stamps.com then have the,
the mailman just pick it up.
If you were less or if you were
just slightly more organized,
you could have an actual business with
all these t shirts, right? You're just,
you're,
you have to do it by herself.
And it's almost like I'm watching one
of those old time wagon wheels go down a
hill and I'm like, God,
it's rolling right now.
But I used to get a be before
they fucking thing. It's
if you look at my house right now,
because I moved all of the merge to my
house now and I'm doing it all from my
living room,
it looks like I'm a psycho and it
looks like my bed is just fucking the
pistachio shells and in my living
room it's just boxes, shirts and buy.
Like yes,
it's time to hire employees,
man. It's time to hire employees.
Take this shit to the next level.
How dare you.
Without stamps.com he would be dead.
There would be no time for him to eat,
breathe and drink water and
he would have died long ago.
But with stamps.com Brian has been able
to maintain a healthy business anyway,
go to stamps.com again entering the
code word jre and you will get a free
digital scale and up to 55
bucks where the free postage,
if you have an idea in your head and
you're thinking about starting a business,
if you actually do it,
it will make your life infinitely better.
If you could figure out a way to get off
the tit of whatever giant company you
work for that doesn't give a fuck about
you and replace you with somebody else
in a heartbeat and figure out
something you like to do, man.
Like if you like to make fucking corn
cob pipes or something, if you like to,
you know whatever you like to do.
There's a way that someone can sell things
online that just didn't exist before
and maybe it's just something you never
considered but brainstorm seriously,
brainstorm. Come up with a
business. You can start yourself.
You could do it with Squarespace and
stamps.com and you would be just sat.
You could actually work for yourself and
you'll get to a point where you'll feel
comfortable enough to quit that Janky
ass fucking job that's been weighing down
your soul.
It doesn't even have to be a job.
One of the weirdest things is that I'd
never use the post office because it was
such a pain in the ass to send like my
family shit back home or my friends and
stuff.
You just have to put it shit in a box and
it costs like $8 for them to get it in
two days and they come and pick
it up and you're trying to work.
So now I'm just sending shit all the time
to friends and stuff just because it's
like seriously super cheap. Like, Oh
hey, have some shit. Hey, here's this.
Yeah, you get a lot of swag. Right?
She always getting things like most
getting t shirts and I'm not going to wear
right books and I'm not
going to read. Exactly. Yeah.
It's cool if you could share that shit
to be able to do it through stamps.com
anytime.
Look,
the idea of the post office or you
know any company that sends you things,
it's ridiculous.
You're going to give you someone how
much I've got to give you 80 bucks and
you're going to take some shit that
weighs 20 pounds across the country. Yeah.
What the fuck is that? That's
ridiculous. Ridiculous. It's amazing.
Like people used to complain about
stamps when a stamp was like 35 cents,
you know, we to 35 cents,
I snuck in 35 cents.
Someone's going to take your letter and
they're going to bring it to another
part of the world.
Like that's amazing.
They're going to take it to the other
side of the continent and it only costs 35
cents and you're whining. You
fucking lazy. Spoiled Bitch.
Yeah.
I love the future shit.
Like this is a great example of a
website taking something that sucked and
making it so much better
and so much easier to where
you could take advantage of
the u sps, you know, for like, you know,
sending stuff to your parents for cheap
and not having to deal with taking it to
the post office waiting in line
to where it's becomes a chore.
Yeah. We have a bunch of
our friends who use it, Tom,
her and Christina budgets to
use stamps.com Bert uses it.
Christ your uses it for Bert, Bert, Bert,
all all his shit or squirt dot. Yeah.
Does Joe use it for his toe?
Probably. Anyway, stamps.com go there.
Get your freak on.
Use the cohort are saved them some
money and enjoy a nice product.
All right, miss pat is here. Why
fuck around Brian Cuban music. Don't,
don't fuck with Nick Diaz,
his voice today. Very
Gotcha.
Some respect experience.
Try my day. Joe Rogan
podcast by night. Thank you.
Yeah, so I want to fuck with his boy.
He just signed to fight Anderson Silva.
Oh Miss Pat. No, I, if I did
not have you on this podcast,
I would have never heard the end of it.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I don't know what you've
done those other podcasts,
but all I keep hearing it's dude,
you got to get ms Pat.
You got to get ms Pat like more than
any recent comedian I could think of in
like the past two years,
people have been trying to get you
what's going on for him. I
don't know what, what's that
about? What are you doing?
What are you doing?
Like a big old black lady,
I guess they think I'm
their nanny and shit.
Well, what I keep hearing as a comparison
to you and my favorite person ever,
Joey Diaz, everybody keeps saying that
you're a female Joey Diaz, which is,
there is no better description
for a comedian that exists in my,
I mean, we shaped the light
ball foul daddy left us.
He's similar. Yeah, and you
both don't give a fuck. I
don't give a fuck about shit.
Life is too short to give a fuck.
It is too short.
I got four kids and two abortions.
I give a fuck.
You can't keep them all.
Yeah. You can't keep 'em all
this times to do things at times.
Not as exactly abortionists
it's a hot topic.
That's a, that's a fucking, uh, it takes
the air out of the room. You fear it.
You feel that.
So the two abortion smoker,
we refer. How dare you,
how dare you implicate us
in illegal drug use. Hey,
I'm might have out of soccer moms
caught writing me, how dare you bitch.
That was 20 years ago called Jesus.
Don't call me and leave me the fuck alone.
Say, how dare you. If you were white,
they might owe a lot of those republican
soccer moms that are really anti
abortion.
Yeah. Black people outside of Bush
and clean. They'd be like, girlfriend,
I feel you. I feel you my
appointment next week. Bitch,
there's a weird vacancy.
Their eyes,
if you ever go to like a or watch a
documentary on those people like I,
I've seen those people.
If there was a planned parenthood,
I think it was in Boston and I remember
seeing these people outside of it and
they would,
when you would drive by and they would
hold up pictures of like dead babies and
stuff like hold up. Like they
harass women as they're going in.
They're like show them these pictures
when they come out and nobody is out there
and he noticed that everybody's gone.
Yeah. Why is that? I don't fucking know.
They probably know when the time when
the rebels was not there when I went, no,
they're not going to protest and they
don't give a fuck about those babies.
You don't have that.
You don't have that problem.
You just have a problem getting the Daddy.
They drop you off.
He cause he don't want to be a part of it.
Abortions. Tricky subject man. You know,
cause it's like at what point
in time should it be okay?
Like everybody can absolutely. I
was, I always say this is my pussy.
I'll do what I want. That's what I
say to her too. But nobody listens.
You believe me?
You can do whatever you want.
Who is Congress to tell you what
to do with yourself? Yeah. No, no,
no one can tell you. Yeah, because once
you have it in, you can't take care.
I two kids when I was 15 what
the fuck was you doing congress?
You had two kids by the time you
were 15 yes. That's crazy. Two kids.
Wow. I didn't have a fucking childhood.
That is incredible. That's incredible.
I don't know how I made it.
It was incredible.
Wow. Well you obviously
made it. You're okay.
You're funny.
Yeah, but I took a loan, went
through a lot of shit to get funny.
He's Christ wasn't funny
when I was having them. Yeah.
[inaudible] y'all were you
when you had your first kid?
I was 14 when I had my first kid
by a married man. Whoa. Hey boy.
I made him when I was 12 and he was 22.
Whoa.
So we started dating. I was in
elementary school. Oh my God.
12. I had a really nice
body. I was fuckable
fuckable today, Joe. But
I was fuckable back then.
When did you start fucking 12.
He was the first one.
He was the first one. You got a baby with
him and you had a baby when you're 40
team. Wow. Tuba ended. I got pregnant
again and gave birth when I was 15.
Goodness. Wow. That is a car.
You never met a teenage mom. Oh, I've met
teenage mom. Well, I'm a old teenager.
I used to be a teenage
mom. This, this, uh,
it's,
it's hard for someone who has children,
especially someone who has daughters.
I can hear the daughters too.
They didn't have any kids. They,
they didn't have the life not in place.
What do they feel like when they hear
your story? That's gotta be hard. I mean,
I guess you'd have to ask them,
but that has to be crazy to hear
that your mom went through that.
Well,
my daughter was dare you know,
she was dare cause I mean I got pregnant
and 14 and I had a brother then I
couldn't get a job. I started
selling drugs. So she was
there through everything.
I mean I think I'm her hero. Wow. So she,
after I got married and I
straighten everything out, you know,
she had a better life.
But
you know,
that's one of those situations where
people that have that attitude like that
everyone on welfare is just,
just lazy like that.
People don't need the help. They need to
pull themselves up by their bootstraps.
Like stories like that. Man,
you got to shut the fuck up.
Let me tell you something. When
you, when you dealing with you,
like I grew up in the ghetto, my mom
was on welfare, her mom was on welfare.
So people, I tell a story
about welfare is like diabetes.
If the mama get it as a good chance to
daughter might get it. So you teach is,
I mean she taught me how to do
this shit and I just said I didn't,
I don't want my daughter to
go through this bullshit.
I don't want my daughter to be a teenage
mom and you don't drop out of high
school.
My daughter's the first one to graduate
high school in three generations and the
first one to ever go to college and
my family. Wow. So I was determined.
You are not going to end
up like how he ended up.
That's beautiful.
That's amazing that that to me is
the greatest form of success ever.
If you can learn from your own mistakes,
important in part your life's wisdom on
your children and then your children go
on to take the ball and carry it and run
it further and do what you just said.
Become the first person to go to college.
Become the first person to graduate
high school in many generations.
That's beautiful. That's a, that's
an amazing thing. Congratulations.
Well thank you.
I mean I worked hard for this shit
because I mean I didn't graduate my nobody
else. I had nobody to look up
to. I just know, I was like,
my daughter would not go through this
bullshit that I went through in life and I
had a son too, so he graduated
too. But wow. Nobody else.
I mean I had a niece to,
cause I had custody of my sister for kids.
So her oldest daughter graduate,
cause they are the same age right
after my daughter day. But nobody else,
everybody just keep having babies and
dropping out. It's so fucking, um,
what do you call it? An
epidemic. Yeah. We know.
It's just keep passing it down.
Yeah. Yeah. Uh, it's um,
there's definitely kids,
everybody from their atmosphere.
That's why I always tell people,
if you can surround yourself with
people that are trying to get their shit
together and we'll help you get
your shit together because you,
you forced yourself to the standard
of the people that you're around.
If you're around a bunch of
people that are real friendly,
you're more likely to be friendly.
You know,
if you're around a bunch of people that
will go out of their way to help people,
you and my likely to go
on a way to help people.
And that's what I did. I
started to surround myself.
I said for me to do better,
I need somebody I can learn from him
because I didn't learn shit from my Mama.
My Mama stayed drunk all the time and
you know I was raised in a bootleg house
so all I saw a drunk people
just bullshit all my life.
So I started to pick my girlfriends.
If you didn't have a college degree,
a high school diploma,
you couldn't be my fucking friend cause
I have a bunch of stupid ass relatives.
He did somebody I can learn,
you know,
this is what put a
correct sentence together,
all that bullshit cause I was dropped
out of school in eighth grade so I needed
to surround myself around better people.
So all my girlfriends got college degrees
and you know they, they married, they,
you know that's amazing though
that you figured that out. Like,
how old were you when you decided to have
these, like really high standards? Um,
probably about 17 cause probably about
17 is when the thing was winding down
from being in a bad relationship with my
kids' father because I, you know, I, I,
I started dating him and I,
I think what I was looking for,
but just somebody to love me because
I didn't have a fucking father.
So I think I was just saying
I need somebody to love me.
So I get involved with these guys
become very abusive. Who shoots me,
who beats me. And then I'm thinking,
you know, cause I was taught these,
my Mama said, if a man don't hit you,
he don't love you. She said, fuck out.
And he hit me with a rollerskate
one night watch. A funny,
this is like the worst advice I've ever
let alone gave me a lot of fucked up
advice that I realize now
that was fucked up advice,
but it was passed down to her. So she
was like, if a man, no, he hit you.
He don't love you.
So like my baby daddy hit me with a
rollerskate run night cause it's food.
Love the roller skate and that fucking
skate shook my skull and I say to myself
at this love bitch I can do without.
I bought up my fist and I knocked that
motherfucker in the back seat and I
started to fight back from that
day on roller skates. He hit me,
he shot me in the back of the head.
He hit me with a bunch of shit.
Shoot you with a 38 Jesus Christ.
Where did it hit you? And it just,
it cracked the back of my skull.
That's it. Just grazed. You know,
I went in a little bit but it was fucked
up cause they, they was, they was like,
I can't believe you're not dead.
So I was in the hospital,
I get better and I call him. It's
like, Oh you love me. Come get me.
That's how fucking stores are
in jail. You didn't call it? No,
I wouldn't tell I was in
love because my Mama said,
oh because I'll slap you a couple
of times. You don't shoot you.
Oh my God. That's real fucking love.
Jesus Christ. He was trying to kill you.
Well he say he wasn't.
You know how fucking good at and you
have to be to shoot to have it in their
head and I was 15 oh my God.
He shot you in the head
when you were 15 holy shit.
Don't going to get shot again
in the titty two shot you.
Who Shot you in the breast? A fucking
fool. Little drive by Blue Minneopa off.
Oh my God.
Where were you sitting when this happened?
No, we was arguing was
that we had an argument,
so I put my pills in his face because
I was a drug dealer. I was like,
get the fuck Outta here before I
shoot you, but I'm just 15 with a gun.
I didn't know you wasn't supposed to
pull a gun unless you're going to shoot a
motherfucker. So he come back
with a 45 and started fucking
pop, pop, pop, pop out.
So I started running and one
of the 45 is hit me up on it,
the arm and blew my whole
fucking titty apart. My God,
it was like stepping on a line,
a lot fee.
And you were 15 and you're 15 with two
kids and you got shot in the of was with
me when, when he shot me she sure
was, she was with me and when they,
when they came to get me,
she was like the police like
well what's what happened rabid.
Cause that was my drug dealer name and
I didn't really want to tell cause I was
like we don't kill this motherfucker.
My daughter yelled at, well, monk,
monk shot my Mama, my mama put a Pilsen
monk face. So he came back and shot.
I'm like shut the fuck up.
You go get me arrested.
Wow.
Oh my God.
And that you're 15 and how old is your
daughter then? She was too. Yeah. Wow.
Yeah, she's two. She doesn't know
what the fuck she's talking about.
She's trying to,
everything she knew every fucking
thing she's still remember to this day,
God is an insane environment to grow up.
And your mom's a 15 year old drug
dealer who got shot in the titty. Yeah.
And a drive by.
Yeah.
And you saw my with dope and
money like crazy every day.
How did you get, did you get arrested?
Fuck yeah, you always get arrested.
Oh was always, let's know. Beating it.
They wait till you earn enough money so
they can take it. Is that what happened?
Yeah,
I did a year in prison for it.
That was the worst day of my life cause
I miss my daughter going to kindergarten
and you can't get that shit back. But
I was just trying to survive. Honestly.
I was just trying to survive.
Well I couldn't imagine
how anybody would function just
being 14 having to fend for yourself,
having kids like what?
You can't
anybody because I was 15
and I needed a work permit.
So a lot of times I would just show up
on the fucking interview and it was like,
where your work put me? And
I was like, Meat Ashland,
Nakheel I need a fucking job.
I got two kids. They like, you're supposed
to be in school. That's here in our day.
I got two fucking kids defend for.
So at that time,
crack had just hit the
black community really hard.
So I started to sell crack because
everybody was getting on it. Wow.
Did you take it? I never did drugs.
I grew up watching my momma, um,
as an alcoholic, so everything my
Mama did. I said I wouldn't do,
she smoked cigarettes. She drank,
she did whatever. I was like,
I'm not going to end up like you
motherfuckers. I think y'all stole me.
Well, you were the the end of the
line, you know, I mean that's the,
that's what it looks like.
I mean,
it looks like you're the one who
figured it out and then you're in.
Pardon that onto your kids.
But the end of the line,
like sometimes enough is enough and
your own genetics were like, stop,
cut the bullshit.
Let's reset this whole thing.
Yeah. Cause you, especially
when I had kids, I was laughing.
My keys can't grow up around this Bush.
I just started doing stand up. Um,
I went to the welfare office to get my
food stamps and welfare recertified.
So you like it a white caseworker and I
tell her, oh, I had such a whole life,
I've been shot, I've been this, I've been
there and you know, white case worker,
once I tell these stories in the detail,
white women, they still easy to make cry.
So this bitch and give me a few extra to
bumps and tell me what was going on for
free. So one day I go in and I got
this black caseworker. So I said, aw,
this bitch is going to be hard cause
you know you'd think all black people is
from the ghetto.
So I started telling her these stories
and this bitch busts out laughing and I
was like, what the fuck are
you laughing? And she was like,
you should be a comedian.
This shit is hilarious.
You ever heard of Richard Pryor
are Richard Pryor store? I like,
I didn't come up fucking
job. I came for free. Shit.
That's hilarious.
You didn't want a job?
No,
I was on welfare.
I mean at the time I was trying to get
my life back together. So, um, you know,
I'm just home had us free free house
cause they had section eight custody of my
sister for kids.
So I had a total of six kids and a
husband who was working and I was like,
you know,
just how I grew up,
motherfucker stand at home watching
the young and the restless.
So you didn't even start to think about
doing stand up until this lady brought
that up.
Well she, the first one it kind
of put it in my ear. Yeah. Wow.
I never thought this shit was funny.
It was pain. See what I mean? You know,
I mean when you tell, when I tell
these stories, I had to get over them.
So you got forgive, yield and
then you got gotta, you know,
you got to let everything go so it
doesn't bother you to tell it on stage.
I can laugh about it now. You know,
people look at me having a, you know,
sleeping with a married man.
I'm 12 and he's 22 that's
fucking child molestation.
But how do you deal with it? So
I deal with it, I laugh about it.
I'm turning all that we'll use and I used
to be pissed off at this dude because
he took my fucking childhood.
I mean, think about it.
I was a mom at 14 that's crazy.
I got a 16 year old daughter that all
she do is fucking play with the IPAD.
Just doing what a 16 year old supposed
to do. I never had that opportunity.
I never had an opportunity
to build a girl.
It's overrated because if it was awesome
in every song,
I wish I was seven again.
I was retarded when I was seven I'd be
playing with mutant Ninja Turtles and
pretended, pretended helicopters are
real plastic helicopters. That's stupid.
That's stupid shit.
I'm glad.
Well
no you're not.
You don't want to,
I steal your daughter's child.
It could be drop kicking
the shit out that old Nigga.
You Ain't get no pussy,
mother. Fuck this cat. Is
it about a guy that would want to do that?
That's what's fucked up.
When you were talking
about like the whole,
you know your family falls into a pattern.
I bet they're in.
I learned cause I'm writing a one
woman show for my, for my life.
And I learned that my daddy
got my mama young like that.
My Mama had six kids by
the time she was 22 wow.
So it's just passing it down.
Yeah. It's so common that that
happens on both sides. You know.
I mean maybe,
maybe your husband or the man who
gave a got you pregnant maybe like
in his fucking husband, man, the dude,
whatever he was at the time.
He was never your husband and ain't
the point in time he was married.
Oh that's fine.
Well whoever he is,
it got Facebook friends.
Huh? Nevermind. I bet
you know, in his life. I bet that
was probably common to, you know,
I bet that kind of fucked
up behavior was normal.
Well yeah.
Yeah.
Cause I mean if you look at it
as child molestation for sure,
to me he's a fucking molester. You know,
we learned later on he did other shit.
But I mean to,
to fuck a 12 year old and you're 22 and
to show up at the hospital and signed
both kids birth certificate. Nobody
questioned your old ass. That's crazy.
That is the most gross
shit out of all of this.
I can not look at my kid's
birth certificate because
on there I'm 14 and he's 22
and my daughter went to get her birth
certificate because she was going on a
cruise and she was like, oh
my God, look, this is nasty.
I was like this put that away. I didn't
say bitch, but I was like put the shot.
Wow. Yeah, it's a sickness.
It has to be this. It's,
and it's a sickness of the mind
and apparently when someone,
when it gets done to them,
it's more likely that they're
going to do it to somebody else.
Yeah. And you know, he never thought he
did anything wrong cause I asked him,
I was like, you know, I'm,
I'm in my forties now.
You actually took my
childhood and he was like,
your mind and body wasn't 12 oh,
what the fuck are you talking about?
My mind and body,
because I had a big booty that was
round and my TV set up like apples. Oh,
I had to come fuck me,
sign on my forehead.
Well that's his way of
excusing his behavior.
He got horny when he was around you,
so he felt like your body and mind.
But you know, when you
describe it, see how was uh,
a man supposed to decipher that if
he's a dumb dude at 22, you know,
he's not going to decipher that.
No, he just wants to fuck. Yeah,
that's the problem.
And it's such an overwhelming urge.
Unless you have someone around
you constantly and partying,
morals and ethics and grow on you the
right way. We grow up like animals.
We have instincts, you know, there's
animal instincts, horny instincts.
They overcome any idea
of guilt or remorse or,
and so that's his way of
rational rationalizing it.
I get a body and mind weren't 14
well my body truly, it was a
four time. It's fine. It's fun
excusing
him. But I'm assuming he was a
dumb dude. Right? He's dumb as
fuck.
He work at Jiffy lubes now.
Nothing wrong with people working at
Jiffy Lube, but I hear you. It's just,
it's, it's hard to get your
shit together, you know,
but you getting your shit
together and your situation,
that's more impressive than anybody,
any normal person in any other situation
because your situation sounds so
fucking crazy that for you
to go full circle from that,
to be in a working professional comedian
paying taxes and yeah, the whole deal.
And on top of that,
the most important thing,
seeing your kids grow up in
a completely different way.
That's all my kids all the time. You
don't know how fucking good you have it.
Especially my second, my second,
my to buy my husband, you know,
we live in the suburbs and they don't
know. She didn't hear a gun fire.
I never had to put drugs in a pampers and
how to dope and sell drugs in front of
their schools. I never had to do none
of that shit to them. So I was like,
you don't know how to fucking get it.
You got it.
Yeah. A lot of people don't, you
know, that's what the old expression,
you know that um,
or the old thought rather than one day
there's gonna come a point in time when
the apocalypse comes and then
civilization is going to crumble.
The apocalypse is already here.
It's just not in your neighborhood.
Like there's spots in the world where you
can go to right now where you might as
well be in Mad Max. Right. There's, how
about Liberia? You hear this shit man,
they're fucking closing the borders of
Liberia cause he bolas breaking out and
people had it.
They escaped from the hospital.
He's fucking people escape
from quarantine. Jesus Christ.
They don't know where they're going.
It's a city of a million people
was it or somebody here in Los Angeles
that just escaped from the hospital also
with some kind of really contagious
disease and they were like,
he has a warrant for his arrest
right now because he just left. If
the hospital did he
take the career went on.
That was that movie,
that strain.
I think you were probably stoned
and you were watching the strain,
that TV show bag with my an FX
show. Have you seen the strain? No,
it's good fucking show, man. I
read the book and I didn't like it.
I liked it for three quarters of the way,
but the last quarter was kind of whack
and I decided that that's not enough.
You know, three quarters really good
and then one quarter of the book sucks.
I can't recommend it, but as a show it's
awesome. It's really cool. That's just,
I think that's what they
were meant they meant to do.
When they made the strain
in the first place,
they meant to make it as a a a mini
series and they wrote it as a book,
but that that's how it takes place.
It takes place at a a disease.
There's a quarantine and these people
get out and then everyone's fucked.
I don't know if you're talking about
just talking about like the ghetto to me,
but I'm just going to listen to,
you were talking about the apocalypse.
I'm talking about terrible situate,
like if your life,
like when you were getting shot
in the tit and you were 15,
you had your baby with you and
you draw a drug deal and all that.
If you forced some white woman in
her forties into that situation,
she would be in, that would
be the apocalypse. That'll
be the apocalypse for her.
I have to sell crack. What? Someone shot
my ted off. Why I can't do this. You know?
I mean,
that would
be just like the apocalypse. There'd
be no different. I found it. It's,
it was actually in north Hollywood.
It was a guy with tuberculosis.
Uh, tuberculosis. Is
that super contagious?
If it gets bad, I think it's something
that like if you start sneezing there,
yeah.
Yeah. But I think they
arrested him. Oh, okay. Yeah.
But they could treat tuberculosis.
Right. That's not scaring me. Like Ebola,
Ebola is a hemorrhagic virus,
which means you believe you bleed
everywhere. Like you boot your eyeballs,
bleed your fucking skin falls apart.
Like Ebola is rough business.
That's no joke.
Those hemorrhagic viruses, when I did
that, a Scifi show, uh, questions,
everything. The, um,
the real issue with that was like
scary on that show was talking about
infectious diseases and they
were talking about, um, you know,
everybody's worried that like there'll
be some terrorists and then released some
anthrax and everybody get
fucked. They're like, listen,
what nature makes the stuff that nature's
making that is way scarier than any
fucking shit that anybody's
cooking up in a lab.
Because at any given point in time,
nature can make some insane virus that
no one can fix at any point in time.
These two viruses can interact with each
other and create some mutant and it can,
they're constantly changing and growing
and they're constantly avoiding the
attack by antibiotics and antiviral drugs.
So they're strengthening and getting
stronger and, and finding new,
trickier ways to get into people's
bodies. You scare me. Can we stop?
This guy's scared the fuck out of me.
He's scared the fuck out of me.
He's one of these dudes was a Russian cat
who told me that when the Cold War was
going on,
they had trenches filled
with anthrax trenches.
And I go, well, how many people
would that kill? He said,
every person on the planet,
every single person. I said,
there's enough anthrax to kill
every person that he goes,
absolutely no question about it.
There's enough anthrax that they had
that could kill everybody. I look like,
what are you talking about?
How much anthrax is there?
Like don't we take like
a little bit to kill you?
Like anthrax is a motherfucker and this
idea was that they were going to figure
out some sort of an airborne dispersion
method and even the government even
tested like there was something, I think
it was in Cleveland, I forget the city,
but they sprayed some shit over this city.
Like phosphorescent like
something that they could track.
They like essentially what the chem
trail people think is going on.
You know like they actually did it and
they did it from the top of a building.
They sprayed it or something like that
because they were trying to figure out
how much of a containment a period,
how much of an area would they have to
contain, you know, if a disease got out.
That's what,
how goofy people are there.
We're thinking about like actually just
it's so indiscriminately just letting a
disease go out. Uh, does
dizzy like that was an option.
I get disease that would kill the
entire pie. Not just the soldiers,
not the people that were in,
you know, the politicians who are
causing the war in the first place. No,
the entire population with a virus,
a virus and make your
fucking eyeballs bleed out.
I think you just scared the shit out
of us should, we shouldn't be scared.
I think we should be scared.
You know why I think we should be scared?
Because look, if the world was just us,
we would work everything out, you know?
Yeah. I couldn't imagine
going to war with you, Ms Pat.
You seem like a very nice person.
I don't think I can whoop you,
but I don't know what I mean it like
that. I mean, you know what I'm saying?
If there was some,
if you had a country that you own
and I had a country that I don't,
I think we've come to some reasonable
terms. I don't think it would be an issue.
But when you see shit like what's going
on in Israel today, you see these,
you know Israel's got, they've got all
their military troops there and there.
Everyone's launching rockets
and it's just horrifying man.
You see in babies that are dead
on the beach, these photos,
Anthony Bordain tweeted some photo the
other day. It was horrifying. Like why,
if that can happen over there,
that can happen right fucking here.
I mean it's contained while it's over
there and our idea is that, well,
if it's out of there,
if it's out of our mind,
but that shit's going on right now in
2014 and it could just as easily happen in
New York or in Pittsburgh or anywhere,
anywhere.
Just pick a city London.
That can happen in London.
Crazy shit can go down like that.
Any part of the world.
If you've got enough people that disagree
and they're highly armed and they have
religious ideas attached to what they're
doing, you got a terrifying situation.
That's how we're living right
now in 2000 and fucking 14
I saw the worst video over the
weekend on Facebook. For some reason,
Facebook has the worst videos now
people are posting on their lines,
but one is this,
a Israeli family that captured it at a
child from Palestine and this kid was
probably like five or six and they're
teaching their daughter who is a Jewish I
guess,
or wetter Israelian uh,
to beat the kid with a s a bat.
And so the kids that cry like,
please stop,
you know,
this look five-year-old and this little
six year olds hitting it with a bat and
she wouldn't, she didn't want
to hit it hard, you know,
so she's just barely hitting it.
And this other kid that's a
little older comes up. No,
because there's no hate him and just like
starts punching this little kid in the
face because the kids Palestinian,
yeah,
they'd like captured somebody and
they're just beating this kid up like the
whole family like that.
Everyone.
Can we go back to the ghetto better?
Eddie Bravo and we watched
that movie once. Um, uh,
what does that fucking movie
is a Brazilian movie about the,
the ghetto o children of God, city
of God, city of got City of God.
It's so fucking crazy movie ever
seen it? No. God Damn is pat.
You got to see city of God. It's
incredible. It's really, really,
really fucking good.
But it's all about the favelas of Brazil
and how the violence there is just on a
completely different level. First of
all, these houses are essentially like,
a lot of them are almost like they're
camping out. Like they don't have windows,
they don't have running water, they have
dirt floors and some of them, you know,
they'd like some them,
they can range
in, you know, like ghetto
to it. Incredibly poor.
Like essentially you live in the woods
and he'd just have like a shelter around.
It's not much different than that.
And these young kid drug dealers just
unbelievably violent and ruthless.
The whole movies just like so more people
die in the first five minutes of that
movie. Then the entire Boyz in the
hood. Dang. Yeah. Like quickly,
like more people die. Maybe in
the first five minutes. It's a Wa,
but it's a good fucking movie to end.
It's based on a real scenario of you.
You go to the ghettos of Brazil,
like some of the worst poor neighborhoods
where there's a lot of drug violence.
That was what they were scared of when
they came to the World Cup. You know,
it's really some horrifying shit QB going
down there that's happening right now.
So there's always somebody that's got
worse. That's how fucked up people I,
this is just a huge range of
what we're capable of, you know?
So when people see fucked up shit that's
going on in the news and they try to
pretend it's not happening
right now because it's on
the other side of the world,
it's like, yeah, well if, if it's
possible right now somewhere,
it's possible here,
you know,
it just a bunch of things we'd have to
go wrong and it could be just as possible
here.
Well let's hope it don't make it here.
We just kind of figured out a way to
get better people to lead the world.
It's that simple.
It's really that simple.
That is the 100% solution for all of it.
Yeah,
there's a lot of problems financially.
There's a lot of problems in this world
as far as politically the different
sides, like, like the, the
argument like you know, I'm not a,
I'm not a a republican by any
stretch of the imagination,
but I believe in some things
that they think make sense.
I'm a big Democrat, but I do believe
in a lot of stuff that they say.
Yeah, well I think the
Democrats, what I like socially,
the attitude of the Democrats better.
I think it's a more progressive attitude
as far as caring for people and looking
after people. And sometimes people point
down at that and they said, you know, the,
the accused people of facilitating the
welfare state and they have all these
goofy ideas about like what it is that
keeps someone in a bad situation like
that. That's the number one problem
that I have with right wing people.
This pull them up by their
bootstraps mentality.
Cause I'll meet someone like you
and I go, what? Fucking bootstraps.
She's fucking 14 years
old and she's got a baby.
You telling me to call another one when
you're 15 you're telling me that she
should be pulling herself up by our
bootstraps. That's fucking crazy.
I don't know other than what
you did though, other than
what you did personally,
where you just realize that a fucking
enough is enough. You worked hard.
You got yourself out of that situation.
How else you're, you've been through it.
If you had an engineer,
the way our society fixes this
problem that we have with extremely
me, I had to, somebody had to make
me realize that that was a problem,
which when I got married, I met him
when I met my husband. He's like,
people don't live like this.
And I was like,
what do you mean people don't
live like this? He's like,
people go out and get a job.
People don't take from other people.
People don't sell drugs. So I had
to be taught that from my husband.
That's crazy. You know? And I'm I,
here I am one 19 I think at the time and
I had to go get a job. How do you go?
How do you go into society and get a
fucking minimal ways job when you used to
making $10,000 a day,
as you know,
when you said 16 and 17 years
old, $10,000 a day. Yes.
I had a fucking trap out of this world.
I mean I don't want to call a trap.
I don't know what they call it now
because I've been gone from the ghetto too
long.
But back then it was called a trap.
So when you saw on drugs like
your neighborhood a trap. Yeah,
you stand on the corner. That's your
trap. If that's what you start doing,
the correct gays or the junkies it calm,
then that's where they came and everybody
knew rabbit was on fast street. Oh
rabbit was on fast street.
That's our trap. Thirst trap.
We need to start calling
our shows traps. Call. Yeah,
we're going to do a trap this
weekend at the Ice House.
It's love that term.
They'll use that term anymore cause I
don't know what you do to sell drugs
anymore. If they didn't use it on the
wire. People haven't heard it? No,
that was desperate because it was, I think
the wire was a little after I started,
so it was probably written by white
people too. But you know what,
this show fucking husband love this
show. And I was like, he was like,
you got to see this show and when I saw
so I don't want to see that fucking shit.
I don't want to relive that crap.
And I got in tonight, you know,
watching the whole fucking, I'll love
it. And he was like, how real is it?
Because my husband comes from a background
where Momma go to church every day
and daddy go to work every day.
And it was 16 old them,
but they wasn't on welfare and daddy and
Momma provided for them where I didn't
have that life, you know, you know
his Mama didn't play that shit.
Want to sell in Joel's, you wouldn't run
in the street. You was going to school.
Wow. So, you know,
so did he, like when he, when he met
you and you said nobody lives like this,
did he offer suggestions or do you just
take you by the hand? Listen Bitch,
we're gonna straighten this shit out.
No, pretty much he was
just like, you know, he,
I think he was, he was attracted because
I was a goal getter cause I was, I was,
I was coming out of selling drugs cause
people had is do you know the crack
epidemic has slowed down. So Nana new
thing was forging checks. So I was,
I was into that shit really
heavy and he was like,
you hurting these people all over the
fucking know these people I know is bank
of America and the check number
is high, you know, and he's like,
you can't do this shit. And he just talked
to me and, and not, and I will listen.
I remember I had a lot of drugs
one day and um, he was like,
I like you and I want to date you.
He said,
but I can't take you home to my mom as
a drug dealer. And your name is rabbit.
So I'm thinking this is the opportunity
for my kids to have a daddy.
And he got all his back teeth,
eddy curry and his shoes clean.
Any little punch a bitch in the eye
every Friday gingy I had to have.
That's hilarious. Wow.
So I, I went for it.
So I gave my niece who I taught
how to sell drugs, all of my drugs.
She, did she work for you or did
you see where the business was?
She was young when I got her,
she was like maybe 10 and they were haul
the drugs for me over the years. So I,
you know, I've taught her how to
do it and she became a drug dealer.
When did she start selling drugs for you?
Shit,
they was probably 11 oh my God.
It was horrible. We was all fucking
keys cause they mom was on crack.
This is my,
this is my baby daddy's sister.
Their mom was on crack so I
took them in. Here I am, she,
I think they're 11 and I'm fucking 15
they think and I'm grown, ain't grown up.
So now I got my two kids and
her three kids and we live in,
I'm taking everybody to school cause
I sold drugs in front of my daughter,
my daughter's school.
So she's fucking crazy.
This will be for the no school,
no drug school zone signs went up.
So I was already grandfathered
in when that shit got there.
That's a really serious federal federal
offense. Right? If you sell drugs.
Yeah. Yeah. But I was already getting
them. Science wasn't up making those days.
So I will drop everybody off at school
and everybody knew when they got out they
knew what to do with the drugs.
That's right. Wow, that is crazy. So
you just had a whole system going.
I had a whole little system going.
So when you decided you meet your husband
and you say, you know, what are I?
This dude's great, um, I'm
going to listen to him.
I'm going to do whatever I have to do
to keep this work and I'll just have her
take care of this. Does she, are
you telling him what to do? She
pulling or you can give her the best.
I just give it.
So I say you can have the
whole trap I'm going to get,
I'm going to give this do to change.
And it was weird because
I had no more money.
I couldn't ride around and my flashy
care lack anymore. The Cadillac. Yeah,
because I had a learner's license and
would Alana's like, she didn't need a,
you need a uh, licensed drivers. So
I will have a crack here for a day.
Different crackers. Hey, you got a
driver's license? Get in the car.
I'm a supply you a car, you know, crack
every hour. I just need the police pulled.
Little pull out your fucking license
so I can drive with my learners. Lice.
Holy Shit. That's how I learned how to
drive a crackhead. Taught me how to drive.
That is crazy.
So you drive and crackheads around
just so that you could drive, they,
that enabled you to do your business.
Yes. To drop off dope pickup. Do it.
Think the crackheads would go,
this chick is fucking 50
and she's got this crazy,
they was giving me get my shit together.
They was scared of me.
How did you have your shit together like
that at 15 just necessity. Lab assist.
Necessity. You know what, my
husband told me, he seen it.
It has a lot to do with my grand daddy.
My granddaddy used to sell a book.
He was a bootleg looker, looker
bootleg house or whatever you call it.
So he said, I never saw anybody
working my family, everybody hustle.
So I guess I got those skills from him.
And it makes, if you grow up seeing
something like that, and I think
that's how people are supposed to live.
Everybody thought I was grown jail.
Nobody knew I was fucking 50 I mean I
had two kids and other kids selling drugs
for me and everybody was like, yes ma'am,
no ma'am. And one day they was like,
how old are you?
And I said,
it's six days like you fucking 16 I had
like eight cars or learner's license in
dry fleet. A crack weight. Yes. They
were like, hey baby. Hey Rabbit,
you want me to drive for you today?
You want to ride in the car?
And I would just apply them rocks and
they smoked the rock while I'm riding
around with run DMC and
whoever was out at a time,
you know invo pumping my music.
Are they smoking crack?
Because I needed a licensed
driver in the car. Wow.
Yeah. It so crazy that no. How
old were you when you got popped?
Um, you know what? I had a police
officer. I was a beer is he said, he said,
I know you selling Craig Bitch,
he's said,
but I'm not going to lock you up
until you 17 cause when it's cracked,
first hit the black community,
everybody went to jail at 18 and you
went to juvenile is 17 but people just go
down there,
yo your kids get caught with a fucking
half a kilo of cocaine and you can get
them right out of juvenile cause they
didn't really know how to handle the
situation.
So they changed the age from 18 or 17
yo has go to jellies 17 in Georgia.
So I had a birthday April the second
Neff fucker had me in jail April to feel,
to seek some shit like that.
I had a cousin that in the
morning everybody went to school,
this is not my color. So my cousin,
I would drop or I'll say, hey,
sell this and I'll be right back.
I'm gonna park the car so I'll crack.
Kay was like rabbit, um, the police's
ups up on the heel, on the ground,
laying down before I could make it back
to pick up my cousin, she was like 15,
he went down there and fucking arrested
her and took her to where she hid the
drugs at. And so he issued a warrant
for me. So I couldn't say it would.
No, he had been on the hill taking
pictures all day. I mean all morning.
So that's how I got my first drug charge.
So how long did you go away for? Oh,
I didn't go away.
Then I got probation and then I
got popped again and then I went,
I was in jail a year.
So when you got probation,
did you have any like idea of like,
okay, I can get caught for this real
easy, I got to get out of this business?
No, I was like fucking, I
thought I was fucking pound.
I was untouchable. I have
money. It's like fuck you,
I'll be out in no time and back did when
you first went to jail, like I told you,
they used to give you bonds but
they stopped giving you bonds.
So I remember I needed,
I had to have a bond here so I had to
pay for the judge in Atlanta to have
fucking dancers and he gave me
a $2,500 bond and I was out.
They have the answers. What do you
mean pay for his holes? You get what?
Whose hose? The judge you paid
for the judges, prostitutes.
How's there was he's there was having
a party. Okay. So my lawyer was like,
you got to put in a few extra money.
He's going to give you a bond,
but you gotta put in a few extra money.
So I put in the extra money,
pay for the holes and it gave me a $25,000
bond.
I called my friend frog who I was selling
drugs with at the time cause we was
partners like,
come fucking get me.
So the judge went and took your
money and got prostitutes. Yeah.
That's hilarious.
I never see any, but that's
what the lawyer you, you know,
that's what the lawyer said.
Yeah.
Kev verify that can go
forward with this information.
It was true that it was,
I mean that's one of those things
that like people would know about.
Did you have that? There's
a judge [inaudible] was
cricket back then. Oh my God,
that's a bad position to put a person in.
Do you remember the judge's
name was a judge Matthews? No.
Who's judge Matthew is a great judge.
Who was that?
Celebrity judges.
Oh yeah.
There's something about being a judge
that I think is unhealthy position.
I don't think anybody should have that
kind of power over someone like to decide
to send someone to jail,
to not send someone to jail,
send someone to jail for 30
days or 90 days or I just don't.
I just think that that kind of power,
I think there should be rules.
Most certainly,
but I think that kind of power bestowed
upon a person to make that sort of a
decision and thrown discretion is just,
it's too much.
It's too much responsibility.
You can't trust someone to be totally
ethical and not fucking crazy.
And people change too.
They get more crazy as they get older and
they get more crazy with ego. You know,
people get nutty.
This,
there's a lot of nutty people that get
a little bit of attention and then they
just fucking go off the deep end, go off
the deep end, believe their own bullshit.
And if you're a judge, everyone's
kissing your ass all day all day,
but you wear the robes, you come
in the honorable, they fucking the,
everybody has to rise where you come
into the room. What kind of Shit is that?
Everybody else has to stand up because
you're here and they call you the
honorable.
Get the fuck Outta here.
There was a guy they busted recently
was using a penis pump while he was,
while he was presiding over cases.
Yeah, penis pump. Awesome. This
is walking any up is paying them.
Sitting there talking to people and
underneath the table he's jerking himself
off with a giant tube and a pump
and they're like, what are you doing
man? And they catch homeboy went flat.
Yeah,
he's
just a guy. He's just a guy. No
one deserves to be a judge. No one.
You can't be a judge. He can't
be the king either. By the way,
you can't be a president.
That shit was for dumb people
that didn't know any better.
We in 2014 with the
information that we have today,
all she need is Google.
All we need is let people vote on shit.
Okay? Let the entire country vote on
every goddamn thing that gets done ever.
You can't have one person that has any
overthe oversight or power over everybody
else, whether it's a judge or
anything, you know, I mean,
I don't know how you would
do it as far as like cases,
as far as like prosecuting people.
I don't,
I don't know how you would
do it without a judge,
but it's gotta be a better way to jail.
No.
Oh. Oh, that's a horrible
thing. The food is horrible.
When I was a little kid and they closed
the cell and they leave you leave you in
there for about five seconds,
San Francisco. So every time I go, he's
like, you want to visit the ACA tray?
I was like, look, you dumb. Fuck
you don't ask a convicted felon.
Do they want to get volunteer visa?
Fucking old jail. No, I don't own a visit.
I architraves I've been to jail before.
I know what he looked like.
There's something also about
people that go to jail.
It's a lot like people that have been
to war or people that have gotten over
some of my very traumatic event is that
they have a certain kind of strength.
There's a certain kind of strength
that a person has when they,
they're the people that decide like,
I am fucking never going back there.
Well, yeah. Some people,
like I got some brothers who had been
in and out of jail out a fucking life.
Some people like going back.
My brother in law's do for me when I miss
my daughter going to kindergarten from
doing a year in jail, that totally
fucked me up. And I, you know,
my by me, by me having that lifestyle,
not really nothing that I chose,
but what I went through. I did not have
a bun with my daughter Joe for years.
And I don't,
I don't know if you have any kids,
but when you have a kid that deeply
probably hate you for the life that you
chose, you know, to, to, to help her,
she didn't realize I was doing this
shit so I can make better for you.
You know,
me missing school and meet me missing her.
Go to kindergarten and you know,
me selling drugs and hurting people.
Me and my daughter did not have
a fucking bond for a long time.
So when I brought my husband into her
life, she immediately bond with him.
But I was always the bad
person. Wow. Well, she probably
looked at him as like the same thing.
He was the savior. He wants to say
she has a bun out of these words.
Now we talk every day.
Even we and,
and you know another thing
is when I went to prison,
then I got out and I really fucking hate
it. And I hate to say this is cause he,
your pocket is so fucking [inaudible]
hope people don't take it the wrong way.
I hated gay women. I don't know.
I could deal with gay men's,
but I saw so much other than shit in
jail. No, I never been with a woman.
Nobody fuck with me because I fall out
of time. But I just hated the shit.
And then when it, when it came into my
life, my daughter is gay, I was like,
Oh fuck, how stupid am I? You can't deal.
You can't judge people and they sexuality.
So all during my,
when I was raising my daughter out,
she always ended up getting a gay fucking
cheerleading coach and I hated this
bitch and my daughter, no, I hated gay
women's. So, but my daughter was gay.
So that's another thing that did not
allow her to bond with me because she knew
my hatred for gay women.
Wow, that's intense. Oh it shit.
So would answer me this if you can.
What do you think it is about the black
community that shuns gay people or shuns
like gay marriage?
Cause I was like a big issue in California
here they had proposition eight,
proposition eight is that what it
is? The Bible's religion. Yeah.
You know, black people believe no
matter what they believe, it's a god.
You know, we'd go on to heaven or
hell, that's just how we taught.
And I think a lot of that shit come from
because our ancestors were slaves and,
and it just, I think it just rolled on
through the genes. But we believe too,
that's what it is. Yes. But it seems,
it's so style 2014 you know,
it seems so discriminatory when you see
that people are born gay. It's just,
I have a gay daughter that
I'm very supportive and I
don't feel that way anymore.
It's almost like a white dude and his
door though to bring home a white,
a white guy, daughter brought
home a black dude. I mean,
you either going to get over it,
a fucking jump off of a
bridge and realize that you,
the person that has the problem, not
them. And that's what I had to realize,
you know, because these bitches was Inga
puts it in jail and I didn't like them.
Well
these are not,
these are not the gay people
who my daughters bring it over.
So now I'm very fucking supportive.
Whatever makes my daughter happy.
Plus you got to remember,
here I am, 15 years old,
getting fucking dogged out by
her daddy. Beat on, shot on,
fucking knocked around,
cheated on, you know,
she just saw so fucking much
that I think turn, you know,
fucking like fuck means them Niggas
ain't right. So I think that that was,
that's part of the issue too. She say she
was born gay. I say in my fucking wound,
bitch, the ultrasound you
is not leaking anything.
So, I mean, do I know, I don't
know if she was born gay,
but she's gay and I support her decision
to be gay. That's my first born.
And I loved the hell out of her. You
know, like when she first came out,
because when she went to college and she
left town because she knew how much I
hated gay women's and I ain't seen
my own fucking child for three years.
I would try to contact her.
She was out in the rural,
been homeless and I was like, what is your
fucking problem? What is your problem?
I said, if you gay, just say
you gay. She said, I'm gas.
What can you come home bitch?
Cause I mean three fucking years.
And now we talk every day we talk.
And I love the hell out my daughter.
She got them. I got a wonderful daughter
in law. They look just like, um,
who did I say? She looked
like? Um, Paula, Paula,
Paula [inaudible],
Paula Robin.
Think my daughter Robin Thicke.
Paula Poundstone you wrong.
No, but I've seen her.
Yeah. So you know, I'm
a supportive mom now.
I mean, I love my daughter. I love my kids
to death. I have four of them, you know,
and we talked about the shit that I'd
taken her through from putting the drugs
in her underwear too. You
know, me dropping out of
school, she was there with it.
But she must feel different about you now.
Shit, I'm not fucking heat around that.
And she's mine.
I mean,
because she did something that I
never had an opportunity to do.
She didn't get pregnant in high school.
She didn't. I mean she didn't, she,
you know, went on and graduated
one when she graduated. Joe,
I say I fucking made it.
I thought it was nothing that you could've
killed me that day because you know
why? None of my cousin kids
graduated. Nobody else.
My fucking Ashley is walking down his eye.
I made it.
I couldn't stop crying. And she was
like, what are you crying? I was like,
if only you knew what I did
to get you to this point,
you broke a fucking cycle that has
been going on in my family for three
generations. I didn't even cry like that
when I took her to college, but boy,
when she graduated high school, I pick up
that diploma once a week and say, bitch,
we made it in a high school
diploma and we'll have shit.
It's about it equals to my GED
yet today, right? Yeah.
Even a college diploma.
It's so hard.
You hear stories about people getting
out of college and looking for a job now
it's like,
it's so confusing.
It is. I mean it's, it's hard.
I met, I tell my kids all
the time, I made my money.
You could probably ever do doing shit
that you really want to do because when
you go to college, you,
you're going for, you know,
you don't really know what
the fuck you want to do.
You want to go and get high and fuck
the first year, that's all. My daughter,
my daughter went to college and I,
you know what?
I paid for her to issue the whole
three years she was there. I said,
because you were not struggle. Do you
know? She went to college in eight,
puts it on my dime.
She Ain't put on my time like crazy.
She was trying to find herself.
Yes.
Losing back teeth and shit.
I was like,
you gotta Stop [inaudible] Pussy.
You gotta Eat Blue Cross Blue Shield.
You lose your back teeth.
We need post when you eat bad pussy
joke. What defines bad? But I don't know.
I can call my daughter.
I don't know.
You know
that is crazy. Wow.
That's a hilarious story.
It's got to be a nice thing to
be where you're at now though.
Yes. I'm happy. How Ain't been doing
stand up 11 years? I've been married 23.
Wow. So, so 11 years ago this uh,
this person at the welfare office
tells you you should do stand up.
So what do you do from there?
I go home and I told him, I was like,
my case worker say I'm funny. He's like,
can you sit down and be quiet? So that's
among, got an open Mike. He was like, ah,
go home pat miles. Isn't that a type
he's not going to say don't do it either.
Whatever. Cause I was in the
process, he must have husband saw me.
You'd go from a drug dealer
to forging checks to fucking,
I got a little Venice service
at the Georgia Dome when
Michael Vick first became
our, our quarterback. So I'm making a
ton of mine money with inner city kids,
with a nonprofit organization.
So he saw me go from nat and then all
of a sudden you want to be a standard.
And he's like, how many time are you
going to change your career? I said,
until I fucking find myself. So I get my
girlfriend, which is a long story short.
My baby's baby mama lived
around the corner from me.
This is a chickie show up at the hospital
after I give birth to his first child.
So she,
we became best friends.
I swear we said we raised the kids,
his cousins,
because she had a baby by him too.
So I get her and I was like,
this case worker say I'm funny, let's
go to open mic. And I go up there,
Joe and I fucking killed. And
I, my first time I told him,
I told a story about my brother was a
professional cat burglar, but he was fat.
So he kicked this lady door and
one time he's like freeze bitch,
I'm the FBI gimme your TV and your VCR.
So I stuck tp and ran out the dough
cause he broken houses everyday.
And that was my first joke. That's
hilarious. And so when you did that,
did you run in and shit?
I don't know cause I grew up in,
I started in an urban rooms, so I started
to follow the arbitrary, I Suck Dick,
I eat booty.
You know how black people do the shit.
You seen def jam shit.
And then I was like,
I look up and I got that drug
dealer mentality. I was like,
well I'm not sticking out. I'm doing
everything and these motherfuckers doing.
And I was like, it's gotta be
something better here. I'm not growing.
I'm make making $50 a week.
This is how to dope gang work because
everything is like the dope game to me.
It must elevate.
And so when my husband got transferred to,
it was either Detroit,
St Louis or Indianapolis and I was like,
you're not going to kill my kids in
those other cities. And he chose,
I wanted to go to Texas, so he chose in
Annapolis. So I'll walk in out with this.
Uh,
I walk into a mainstream club at a time,
which was mortise and I got
this urban flair and he's like,
not here bitches. We don't do roaches
jokes. So it forces jokes. Yeah.
Roaches. You know how you see a black?
Yeah. You haven't had a roach drank out.
Y'All cool late. Oh I
get it. Yeah. You know,
you're not roaches, you
know, and, and the uh,
then you got the jokes about
the government cheese and shit.
So when I moved to Indianapolis and they'd
be like, you can't do that shit here,
you know, no matter, no, no,
I didn't have fucking roaches.
Where the fuck are you talking about?
So it forced me to open
up to my life that I had,
which was way more interesting while,
so you were trying to just do what
everybody else was doing and then go into
this white neighborhood going to the
white neighborhood when we moved. Fuck me.
Fuck me. Cause I never been, you know,
like I never read club. Yeah, it is.
Yeah.
It's a great club.
I've worked there before and it was a
little black owner at the time when he's
in jail for bank robbery
and that motherfucker
last year with no guns, just showed
him all 32 of his cabinet get up.
When I got to in Annapolis,
I had to change who I was,
so I had to find myself and I just
started talking about my life, which was,
you know,
kind of embarrassing to kids that are
15 dropped out in eighth you know,
you'd think if people go on fucking,
I thought I was the only
teenage mom on the road.
I thought I was the only bitch and I am
the only one probably missing the nipple
that's going to tail.
But all of this stuff that happened to me,
I thought it was just me.
Did I learn fucking teenage pregnancy
happen in every race? Yeah. Well,
there's a whole show on it.
You know what the fuck was that
show at when I had my baby?
You better off without it. You're
better off becoming you and now. Yeah.
Getting famous. You could
handle it better. Yes.
So when I got to Indianapolis,
Shit changed.
I moved to a white neighborhood and
I just started to work on my sip.
So do you do a right like material or
do you always talk about your life like
I right like stuff about
being married key is,
most of my stuff is personal so
you know where everybody gets it.
You know my life,
you know middle drug dealer.
I talk a lot about my mom
who was an alcoholic mom who
used to give me the worse
is vice.
Like she was like shit,
like a reach for the stars and I
hope you hit this sun and burn up.
So it was true.
I told my husband the other day,
my mom was so fucking stupid. She was,
I'm not going to say she was stupid,
she didn't know shit
like she couldn't read.
So she will force me to re Jahari scope.
But when she didn't know
I couldn't read either.
So I would just make up shit every day.
I made a bullshit bullshit.
And she went forward.
Like I was saying cause she was shooting
at us like she told a 22 pills her
because she was, my mama was a very small
lady so she walked around a 22 pills.
She's carried it everywhere. Oh yeah. And
we're like, we wouldn't wash the dishes,
washed them goddamn dishes and we
can shoot it into the ceiling. Yes.
And when it rain it showed,
so when it rained,
water would come dripping through the
halls and she left by shooting the scene.
Yeah.
There's one,
why don't fuck the ceiling league cause
bitch you don't put 22 of them holes in
the ceiling or what the
fuck are you talking about?
Wow. Yeah. That's a way
to motivate kids though.
And we will shoot out to her.
We were scared of her. She did.
She was never pointed at us. He was
like, I'll just shoot a light out. Wow.
So God damn,
what we got used to him like
he go mama with is bullshit.
Did she ever shoot at you?
And he shot at me one time
I was on the phone with my baby daddy.
I was on the phone with my baby that she's
like get the fuck out. The phone's on.
My mom was like pre handicap cause we
lived in the project and the security
guard fucking body slammed him
fucked up her spine. So she is,
she sit down, she couldn't get met
good. So we had to be that a lift up.
So I knew I wanted to talk a little phone.
My Baby Daddy,
it's time I'm at this time I'm
pregnant with my second child.
So my mom was like get off the
phone with that motherfucker.
He's going to get you pregnant.
That's somebody else husband.
So I tell my kids while I was like
hold on, why go ahead and lay her down.
And she was only like 98 pounds.
So I picked up and later in the
bathroom on the floor and I'm like,
you stay right there until I get
through talking to my baby daddy. What?
I didn't know Joe is that bitch go crawl.
She crowd on that
bathroom like military style with
that shotgun and shot at my hand.
I flew out the door.
She shot at you with a shock shotgun.
What a shot gun.
She got it out of the closet.
She got it.
She shot at you with a shotgun because
you were on the phone with a man and you
put her on the floor?
Yeah, put on the floor and she
couldn't get up, so I was like,
if you don't start shooting, who the fuck
gonna get you off the floor? Oh my God.
So how did you guys resolve that
age? He ran out of bullets. Oh,
what did she shoot? Does she shoot
just holes in your house? Yeah,
she would just shoot up anything. We
will give up getting evicted. It wasn't,
she was like, you would be watching
the TV and she would tell you to move.
She'll blow the mother fuck
out if you didn't move.
Really?
How many times you shoot the TV?
Just once because we
can afford another one.
It was only to wanting to know
for the kids and one for her.
How much material do you think?
Like I would say,
if you're going to become a
big name stand up comedian,
you're going to have to put
out a bunch of specials. Right.
So if you put out how many specials can
you do on your life before you have to
start talking about other shit?
Probably four or five. Four or five
specials. Just cause you know what?
A lot of stuff that I remember like it
was so at the time like I can laugh at it
now, but back then it was paying. So I
didn't get on drugs like my sister did.
I didn't,
my brother did and got on drugs to deal
with bullshit that we was going through.
I just, they, you know, sobering
thought he loves goes crazy.
So to get rid of the pain, I just kept
putting it in the back of my head.
I didn't want to remember it.
So when I became a comic,
all of this shit start rushing
through my brain and how the x,
my sister bitches this real,
I just asked my sister the other day,
my granddad and ran a bootleg house.
So in this bootleg house,
I had a retarded uncle named
uncle Cecil that was crippled,
but my granddad or we'll
buy him pussy on Friday,
but me and my sister would have to go in
there with the prostitute and hold his
legs back until he get his dicky
before we could go outside and play.
So I called her up and I said,
is this shit
you get a hold his legs back cause these
will cripple you know how when they
need,
well he couldn't get it in until
we move to this fucking legs bag.
Wow.
Oh I remember what to ask.
Like hurry up probably eight.
I was like, oh see so stop fucking
smile because they were retarded. He's
awful. He's so fucking off. And
I asked my brother, I was like,
do y'all remember this shit? I'm
going crazy and all. I'm like,
come on brother.
Last weekend I said my mommy
had his theory. She's saying when
when it rains and the sun is shining,
the devil was beating his wife. You
ever heard of that? Yes. And then she,
if it will rain and lightning and
the son was shot. He called him miss
g. He's always, he's, my mom was like,
you should be the beach cause she
don't believe in God fucking damn.
I used to,
they stole me
Joe and it's fucking crazy.
He should beat her.
She doesn't believe Holy Shit.
And she shooting at you.
She's a shoe.
I was just thinking the irony in that,
you know,
does God want you shooting your fucking
Jesus Christ?
I can't hear you ma.
Well the trigger. Oh my God. Wow.
And we was getting her ass for years. We
were scared of her. Well in her defense,
probably very hard to raise a bunch
of kids. What happened to her back?
Someone slammed on her bag. Okay. We lived
in the projects. She was the candy lady.
So she, my Mama, my Candy
Lady, Candy Lady, that's when
that's the late in the hood.
They sell the free freeze, pop the
candy, the cookies to the kids.
And my momma did it because we was in the
project and that money helped her with
her light bills or whatever the fuck.
And she used to talk shit
to the security guard.
This back for the projects were really
dangerous. So the security guard was like,
Mildred,
you,
you cannot sell candy because it's fucking
earn income and you're not reporting.
But he was just fucking with him because
my mom had talked to a lot of crap.
So she's like, Oh fuck you security to
God, you're ugly face whatever she said.
So he came on, he says, I'm
gonna come whoop y'all aids.
And I had to be about probably seven.
That dude came in and beat the dog. Shit.
I was into wrestling at the time
he was in a DDT and his shit at my,
before he came in the house,
she gave me my sister to cash,
like go flush this shit.
He owned away.
So we're in the bathroom popping pixie
stick like cocaine eating the shit.
He Ain't no whooping her ass.
So he,
he hit her up against a wall
and fucked her spinal. Whoa.
So she sued the housing authority,
but she couldn't read and the fucking
lawyer took all the money and we got put
out of the projects. So, oh, that's
what that when it damaged her spine,
like she could no longer
hold of her neck up.
Like if she be talking
that bits fall over.
So she had to keep us to keep our
up while she was driving all mine.
One incident with this guy did
that? Yes. She was like 90 pounds.
What happened to him? I don't know.
I was a kid. I don't really know.
I remember going to court and
testifying, you know, you know,
uh sorry I got grace jokes about it.
You know,
cause like
she would do shit.
It's e even though her
neck with fucked up,
she was determined to do nominate people
shit like going across the drug to
like go across the track too fast.
And once I see she had a 64 Chevy that
used to bounce and she loved like old
music.
So we're not just bouncing,
listen to BB king and she
going to beat the train.
That bitch hit that first tracking that
she's like coming muscles to slap the
shit out of her neck and then went through
the most stern.
We had to jump out to sea in Hola.
Nica she drive across the track.
She pulled out yo pitches hit me too hard.
My son was like miss the train was
coming. Oh my God, you bitches.
Holy Shit. So she could, she could walk
and she could use her feet,
but she just had a bunch that I know
about that she had a boyfriend. My house,
he couldn't so he knew, cause he never
called us in. Now the picker Nica
is that what you would draw the line?
I want to wait and pick the neck up.
I hit my crip arc or fuck.
It just seems different though.
It seems like one more level.
I mean not everything went.
It's nothing that I did not
see as a key murder. Fuck yeah.
I tell you before I tell you about myself
more murder. When I was a drug dealer,
that's when I really saw myrtle. But I
had a guy and I lived in our backyard.
W W well we lived in some apartments
and this is when heron and she came out
very popular in the black community.
So my next door neighbor used to shoot up,
but my mama used to shoot up too,
but it was diabetic medication.
So I will walk out there and as I walk
out the side one day on the back porch
and I'm sitting there, so he shooted
what I thought was diabetic medication.
He get bud as naked Joe run over
to me, Ben Dover, he's like rabid,
get the red out of my ass. So I'm looking
up this dude as for a rat and I'm like,
JB has no ready your diabetes fucking up.
I was like,
the red is hanging in the front.
So he thought he got nick and
every weekend nobody said Shit.
You were telling him was his diabetes
medicine. That's what I thought it was.
Bs Medicine has you thinking is right
up your ass. But it was, it was heroin.
I learned. We learned later
that he was shooting arrows.
So it when he got naked on Friday,
we're like, Jamie, I just high.
He'd be all right. There's
only one day he got naked. No,
he got naked every time he shot drugs.
How many days a week to be shoot drugs?
Shit, two, three. So two
or three days a week.
He was naked on some people
care. Some people can't. Like
when he wasn't, you know,
he was a fucking, and he was an
engineer for living and engineer.
Like he designed things. Yes. That's what
he did for a living. He got on heroin,
very engineered. Running a train.
No, not like that. He designed shit.
He was like fucking corporate America.
He was the shit.
But he came to the ghetto and
got high and take off all.
He felt so embarrassed once
this high came down. Wow.
And people would just let
Gebo walk around naked.
I wonder if that's like his way of
releasing all the stress of keeping all
wrapped up,
tightened corporate America.
I think he thinks stuff
was crawling on him.
So he was just getting negative
indeed his ass. And we'd be like, oh,
Jay badges naked. He
just hides in his ass. I,
before we moved in these 44 we
moved in this set of apartments,
I would go to the wrestling match every
week when we moved in this or set up
apartments, I stopped going because
it was nothing to see people fighting.
And you know,
motherfuckers out there acting a fool.
It was more interested set on my back
porch and there was real wow. Dot.
It's crazy. Dot. It's gotta
be so bizarre. Be that young.
You get a pull one guy's legs
apart to see how big fuck.
Another guy that's running
around naked and he's on heroin.
That was the norm when you
were in this situation.
Nothing else seems what you doing
the right shit is out of place.
What I'm doing, this is what
I'm used to. If that's okay.
We're thinking about human beings
are very adaptable, you know,
that's what they're saying about
people that live in any country,
watched tribal people and you go,
why don't these people don't have any TVs?
They don't have any electricity. Like
they don't even know what that is. Like.
This is normal to them.
And you see people in those villages,
they find in the Amazon, they don't
have any contact with human beings.
We feel bad for them. But what are
they doing? They're just being people,
being people that figured out
how to live there, you know?
And you were a person who figured out
how to live in your, your wild world.
How wow.
Or that was a wild world.
I mean it might as well just been the
wild of the Amazon or the wild of the
forest or the wild of the city. It's
just wild. There's varying degrees,
right? Yeah. Cause there's,
there's places where shit is just wild
and where you were living craziness.
So we should make a movie about your life.
Like you should.
That's what you should do. You should
write a movie, be all the best stories.
Completely, totally factual.
Completely, totally accurate. Insane.
That would be a fucking chaotic movie.
Yeah. I'll see a 15 year old girl,
a 15 year old girl,
get her tits shut off while she's
holding her baby and dealing drugs.
And this guy's running around naked.
He's got a rabbit up his ass.
And you're thinking he's
on diabetes medicine. Yeah,
I was naive. Fucking tell you
more stories please. Please do.
I was about probably,
but like I said,
I was about 10 or 11 so I
had a really nice figure.
So I learned 10 you had a nice figure.
I was fuckable this,
this third grade honestly.
Are you sure? Yes.
No.
So how do you know?
I remember everybody used to say I was
fine and I didn't know what fine was. Wow.
I tell you this story.
So I'm body 10 or 11 so sometime
I could just walk away from home.
Nobody gave a fuck. So I go downtown
to the locker, a Hilton hotel.
Cause I said I want to go see
what white people doing. You know,
rich white people. Cause I thought
everybody stayed at the Hilton was a rich,
you know, and plus I went in there
because we didn't have no fucking AC.
So I was standing in front of the
door when the door was open at AC,
hit me in my fucking face.
So I'm standing at the phone booth
one day and this white man say, hey,
you want to come and go to my room with
me? I'm like, Huh. And he thought like,
like he's jacking his dick and I was like,
okay.
Honestly I go to his room,
Joe and he had me,
Jackie's Dick and I jacked this white
man did and he paid me $100 I'm like,
are you going to fucking be here tomorrow?
So I'm thinking,
this is my first job.
I go home and tell my mom I got a job
downtown Jackson white men's Dicks for
$100 you told her that?
Yeah, she wanted to go.
God
Oh oh dollars in the
ghetto for jacking digs.
Who might get some oatmeal cookies?
You don't get no damn hundred dollars
Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.
How old were you at the time is 1111 you
told your mother you got a job jacket
off white men's Dicks for $100 and
she wants to go with you. Yeah.
That might be the craziest fucking
story to tell so far. Say it.
They're not hiring you to
fucking, oh, you're not
the only at 14th.
And she wasn't really cute.
It's funny that you have to qualify
that he 14 but she was cute.
As fun as she wasn't cute
at all, you know, but you,
I mean once you only have four teeth,
it's like what is really cute?
I don't like your tone.
Something about being toothless
is not that appealing to us. Wow.
That is so crazy. Your mom
wanted to go with you? Yeah.
Well No,
it was
when I was, um, where was all
this go? What city was this
again? Atlanto is awesome.
It really started in a bootleg house.
This is the one I knew she was fucked up.
Like on Friday,
my grandfather customer was just
fall asleep and why they were sleep.
My Mama would make me rob them and
for every person that I robbed,
I got $5 per person and I
probably was seven or eight.
I remember that shit like yesterday and
I told us that you taken advantage of me.
I should be making more money and so
extra for 10% cause I had been watching
sesame street but neither
one of us knew what the fuck
for 10% of the robberies cause
you were watching sesame street?
Yeah cause all she didn't know what
it was and so I was like it's $10
cool.
So she gave me $10 for every wallet that
I stole and I fucking would get up on
Saturday morning and play Pac
man to love fucking sun. Go down.
Well I only did it cause
I wanted to play pac man
that
credible. Yeah. What a crazy inbox.
Now growing up and then getting
past that and looking back on it,
like when you were asking what does
this really happened or am I crazy?
Like how does that feel now when
you tell these stories, you,
you being this normal person now,
you know it was normal as you can be
having children that are doing great,
living in the suburbs,
staying calm like this.
This has got to feel like another life.
Right.
It is another lie. Yeah. Wow.
I used to hurt me like it used to like
I would cry when this shit come up and I
was like I'm not doing,
I have,
I have this whole thing in life
and shit don't get me down.
And I learned that from a fourth
grade teacher cause I, you know,
I used to go to school,
I'll just stanking kid.
I was a poor kid but I had
a teacher named is true.
That would tell me Patricia get earlier
and I will bring you clean clothes and I
will call them your hair.
So we were in the bathroom one day and
she just was combing my hair and she said,
I want you to remember that you can be
anything in a rural, you won't to be,
all you gotta do is believe. And I
laid, it just died this year. And I,
when I did time in prison,
anytime I got low or anytime I wanted to
question something that I was trying to
do in life, I went back to
miss truth. Cause she to me,
she was the first person
to ever believe in me.
And I'm 42 years old and I
still fucking quote Ms. True.
That's crazy.
Isn't it amazing how one person like
that can have an impact to think of those
two people's impacts?
The One lady that told you your funnel
and then that lady telling me, yeah,
the casework is my God mama now
I still talk to every day. Wow.
Yeah, she was married. She
must be blown away by it.
When I got more than dealt with
this stores like, you know,
after I tell you all the story,
they'd probably take a month.
You know that people call me.
Can you tell me this story one more time?
And a lot of time they remind me of Shit.
How many do you write these down?
Do you ever write them down?
You just confident you're
gonna remember them all.
I do remember mile gas.
Well,
it's like the sex that
you work in all like Nah.
Talks about my mom and my aunt
and I talk about being married.
So I really don't need the cripple,
Uncle Jack and d, You know,
right now I tell that story
later on in life on stage.
I talk about being a drug dealer.
Nothing, you know, just the basic,
just stretching the surface. Right.
You know, cause I'm not a star,
so it was only so much.
You can put that down before you
make your fucking audience cry.
[inaudible] so you know, when
you, when you become Chris Rock,
they'll take anything from you.
But I'm going to miss pat fucking nobody.
I got to give it to them either.
And you got to remember I'm a fucking
black woman talking to a white audience.
Most of my fans are white.
I have no fucking idea.
I appreciate y'all to the
fullness. Hey, I love the fuck.
I don't give a fuck if you had one.
I thank you for supporting me.
What do you, what do you think it is
about the audience being all white?
Like how'd that happen?
I don't know.
Honestly, I don't, I did a radio show
called Bob and Tom and in Annapolis.
That's why I got a lot of them from,
and they just started coming. I mean,
I would go into that mainstream club,
you know,
mostly white people and I would tell
these stories and people be like, wow.
And that's the how people would
be like want to cry. I was like,
get the fuck away from me. I'm not fucking
crying over this shit. I'm over it. Wow.
It's just because they don't have
anything like that in their life. And you,
I think people like to know
that you overcame, you know,
I could be on crack like my sister,
my sister been smoking crack from day one.
She's been on drugs all of life and I
think that's how she dealt with her pain,
a fucking molestation and all that
bullshit that we went through. His keys.
She'll never admit it because she
haven't faced up to the problem yet.
Well with me, I just pack the shit
in the back of my head. So I think,
I think when I tell my stories,
people at home going through whatever
they're going through and they was like,
fuck,
I thought my problem was big on Hell No.
This bitch at the pool or cripple uncle's
leg back and help him stick his dick
in it. Eight. So you realize
your life ain't as bad as you,
I think after you hear my story,
wow. Fuck hey good pants. That's
a feel good story of the year.
I can't even imagine.
Yeah.
So you start 11 years ago, you started
telling this on stage and when,
when you first started doing it,
will you do on it?
You would do an open mic nights.
When I started talking about my life
about six years ago when I moved to
Indianapolis.
So six years ago?
Yeah.
So the five years before that you
were doing all black clubs? Yeah.
All in Atlanta.
And so then you were,
you were more like everyone else around
you just trying to like do whatever
everybody else did try to get laughs.
Yeah. So moving to Indianapolis.
Does that when you started getting
paid work or were you getting paid work
before that?
Um, I started getting paid, working in
Annapolis. I became, I became a comedian.
I was bullshitting the whole first
time and my husband used to always say,
nobody want to hear it,
chicken shit on stage.
And I didn't know what he was talking
about. He was like, it's not funny.
I mean he wouldn't say it to hurt my
feelings, but he said he wouldn't,
he wouldn't support it. He never would
come see me. He's like that, that,
that ain't funny. You
know, anybody can talk,
why are you going to talk about your
bedroom on stage? And I was like, oh,
you just fucking hey.
But when I became Ms Pat,
who I am today with my life,
he's more supportive.
Like when I say I'm going to do
Joe Rogan Park case, he was like,
here's my credit card,
but before bla,
I'm not giving you no money to
go tell him fucking roast jokes.
So it makes a difference. Like
he only seen me once. What? Yes,
once a cat Williams, when I open for
Kat Williams, he invited them out.
That's the only time he's ever seen you.
Cause you know what he said,
I will never funny to him. I
was always serious. And he say,
people just laughed at what I say. They
thought what? I was trying to be funny,
but I would just being me.
Wow.
So for him it wasn't funny.
No, because you know what? When I did Bob
and Tom and I talk about being my baby,
daddy shot me in the head. Another do shot
me in the titty. Uh, his, his coworkers,
there's a you chateau wife Teddy
out. He's like, that was a fucking
ass an abuse. Questions
about me. He's like,
you snap your wife. What does gay
like, dude, that was not fucking me.
That was the dude before
me. Oh, that is welcome.
Before I met this dude.
Wow.
It's your nipple like together still
or is it just like God, no, no. Is it,
is there, it's a little,
some of the damage,
but it's there and you have
a piece in its store, right?
You said you were saying no,
what I was saying when I do my
mammogram and they smashed my boob,
you can see the uh, the gun. What
does it call the gun? The right,
the
frag me. Oh, my mama
would fragments. Yes. Wow.
Bus. And it looked like breast council,
but they know it's not breast council.
So they have on my chart and my mammogram
off has been shot in the right. Yeah.
Data missing them because I say to them
on your mammogram or whatever, boom, grass
calling a titty. You might want to like,
where's your fucking certificate man?
Where your diploma and almost go.
They always titties Joe always. Yeah.
That's a good name for him. I've got no
problem with that. What do you call them?
These are great. Okay. I
have a friend who says,
my friend Steve says tds for things
that are good. He's like, ah,
we're going on a titties, camping
trip. It, I mean it's good. I say tick,
that's tits or the tits boobs.
I don't have boobs.
I got TD,
my shit and high and he's like balls
and I have to put grease up on them so
they'll slide across my stomach easily
so they don't fucking create fractures.
She didn't make us soar. Oh No
really? I got real shit. Joe,
we were talking about your husband before
the podcast started about he became a
Vegan. Lost a ton of weight last time.
Oh 100 and some pounds. That's crazy.
Yeah, he's, his health was going down. I
mean knees and shit, her and everything.
And he just said,
I'm not eating this shit anymore.
Well if you're a hundred
pounds overweight, big guy,
he might be God carrying
an extra hundred pounds.
Like everywhere you go you have to put
a hundred pounds in your shoulders.
Everything will start
breaking after awhile.
That's what most people are doing
that are a hundred pounds overweight.
They just don't think about it. Right?
Yeah. So he got his shit together,
became a Vegan eating meat in
two years. Wow, that's crazy.
And did you, do you stick
food in his face? Like smell
this bitch. It don't bother.
My husband is so fucking strong minded.
This is more for going on a 40 day
water just per water. I was like, oh,
you fucking crazy.
We can't live on just water.
He drops so much weight just on
water and went to work every day.
That's crazy. You're not supposed
to do that. That's what I tell him.
I said stupid fucker on face on youtube
that told him he could live off water.
I was like, look at your fucking
titties. They're fucking just gone.
You need to eat something.
40 days, 40 days of no eat,
drink juice, nothing. He didn't
even brush his fucking teeth.
He breast and with water supplement.
There's some kind of, no, he didn't.
Well, let's see. How many days
do you think it says online?
I'm not saying his story's not true,
but if you can call me,
you know I believe him,
but I'm saying how many days I did you
think it says online that you could only
drink water before you die?
I did a 10 day water,
lemon fast where I couldn't,
we didn't do no limb and he
didn't write how many days.
I would say you could live to be 30 days
with just water and maybe some stuff,
but I think it's 21 or you'd be
dead like the last two weeks.
I think that's like this.
Isn't that the story behind
drunkin and afraid or not drunk
and afraid naked in the phrase,
don't they?
Don't they say that like it's 21 days
is the day? Hmm. Okay, let's find out.
Can you live off?
Only water will go to Yahoo answers.
It says the average person could,
depending upon your body fat.
The average person go from a week
to one month or so without food.
So this guy went 40 days.
He liked probably hit the boundaries.
He was so, she was shaking so bad and
I was like, can you please fucking eat?
How are you just going to down me?
I don't even know what a policy yet.
Got it so crazy. He had to do
some kind of supplement. Okay.
There's a hunger strike Wikipedia page.
Apparently you could
live as many as 74 days.
That's the longest a person's
ever gone with. Just having water.
Oh my God.
Hunger strikers dying after 52 to 74 days.
So 74 is a big one.
That's ridiculous. Yeah. Gandhi,
Gandhi apparently went through a
bunch of a hunger strikes when he was,
I didn't know Gandhi was real alive
so young. Oh, so long ago. It was 19,
22.
Yeah.
Only way I can go on a hunger strike
is they shut down all the chick filets
did you get mad on Sunday? Why does
chick filet have to be so religious
Sunday? Well, by that
time I don't fucking soak.
All of that crept into my body so much.
I love chick fil A's so much.
I made my son got his first job
done so we can get a discount.
Wow. It was, um, there's,
there's certain people that are,
uh, that are famous hunger strikers.
Apparently a guy who fast it to death,
his name is a boy.
Try and pronounce it as
j a. N. T. I. N. D, a.
S job Tin dos maybe.
Um,
it was a hundred 16th day of his fast.
They gave up their hunger
strike surpassing the 97
day world record for hunger
strikes,
which was led by an Irish revolutionary.
So apparently you can fucking do that.
You can not eat for 40 days like your
husband did that. He's crazy though.
Like he was probably on death's door.
I know. He was so fucking, we ain't,
he went to work and work the eight.
My husband's deal. Uh, the
transmission for Allison transmission,
that's a crazy way to
decide to lose weight.
I mean, he just wanted to cleanse
his body. You know, what sells,
what do you know? His ski
and turns so pretty. I found
his kid's skin changed,
became super smooth.
How many days in two is fat? I didn't
really, cause I've, you know, I traveled,
I tried when I was, at that time I
was traveling a lot. So you know,
I come home and I was like, Goddamn,
you losing a lot of weight, dude.
They're not fighting you on a fucking
wall. I was like, you need to fucking eat.
Yeah. What, did he ever get to a point
where you're worried about him falling?
Yeah. No, not really falling asleep
driving and I was worried him fucking,
he was always cold, so I was
like, you call you back to die.
What the fuck are you on? Leave me here.
Would he chills? I got to do gates.
Wow.
So then when after 40 days you start to
eat and he starts eating and what did he,
he uh, he started to like
fruit. He went into fruit first.
Just real gentle. Yeah. Gotta be
a big shock to your system. Yeah,
that's what he said.
He didn't want to shock his system.
He does this shit all the time. He
don't get go that long. And I'm like,
am I can go 20 days, 15 days. Really?
I've heard of people doing like
six days of juice. That's it.
Want me to call him and ask? No,
I've listen. I'm not questioning.
I'm saying I don't know anybody who's
ever done that very extreme dude.
He just liked it when he,
when he just, I tell you,
he used to smoke cigarettes and nobody
knows this and he just stopped and he
started may one time when I got arrested,
he went to court with me when I was
getting my life together and I needed my
driver's license and to just say,
you have $5,000 worth of traffic tickets,
how you want to paint it. And
so my head was like, your honor,
I can only get $500 out at
one, you know, during the day.
That's it. He said, well
you gotta go get some money.
We're going to lock her ass up.
He started back smoking cause
he never been to jail. Wow.
That's the hardest one. Probably quitting
smoking. No, he went cold Turkey.
He and after I got out of jail he stopped.
He did it again by the week.
He always do every fucking
thing called tick Joe.
I've been trying to lose weight forever.
I've tried all the nice shit out there.
Nutrisystem did work,
but I can't afford the shit.
So now I'm back at my ex like diet
cause that's really cheap. Excellent,
excellent.
Take it and shit your brains
and he gets mad at me cause I do excellent
and I'd get mad at him cause he do
water. I think x lacks is
probably worse for you than water.
I know I do the mouth phone the mile
for but I mean all that's stuff is a
diuretic, right? I mean what does it
do? It makes me shit. I've pounds.
Like if I could eat a cheeseburger,
I really want to get rid
of this cheeseburger.
Is the based diet a way to do it?
I know Joe was sometime I
can't resist chick filet.
I like coffee and I really can't drink
coffee because I got sensitive nipples.
Coffee make my nipples
really sore and I'm most,
I'm seriously nipple.
Caffeine fucks my breasts up.
I got caffeine breath, some called
caffeine breath and women's out there.
Who's listening? They know. I'm telling
the truth is a common term. Yes.
When you drink too much caffeine
it fucks with your titties.
So I just went and had a mammogram.
I'm just my left titty two weeks ago.
Wow. Because I had too much caffeine.
So when I lay off the caffeine,
my breast stop being so,
but I like chick filet
called fibro breasts. That's
what it's called. That's the medical
term. Yeah. Fibrosis stick guests. Jamie,
you googling everything constantly.
I'm constantly curious.
Yeah. Pain or discomfort in both breasts.
Pain comes and goes with the period,
but can last through the entire month.
Breasts feel full, swollen and heavy.
Yeah.
And Caffeine does until my breasts.
Well,
my nipples are hard to sit in a bra of
the wrapper mint at the wrapping and
tissue paypal. Wow, that's crazy. But
coffee fucks me up. But I love it.
Some women get it from eating chocolate.
You drinking caffeine or eating high fat
foods that causes their symptoms. Uh,
but according to this medical page,
there's no clear proof
of what's causing it.
When I come off of caffeine,
my titty stopped being so honestly I
know my titties. Well, it makes sense.
Fibro, cystic breasts, the breast,
and that's what it's called. Painful,
lumpy breasts as lump. And it almost
make you feel like you got, you know,
like you feel alone.
So I went in two weeks ago and I was like,
I'm very paranoid cause breast cancer
run in my family. So on my daddy's side.
So I was like, just check my
damn titty. So my doctor know,
I said if I could take of my doctor,
I fucking love my doctor.
Like well he'd given me a
gynecology visit. I'd be like,
how did this blue cross
blue shield pussy look. Dot.
Oh they gave me a mammogram on
one breast and they're like,
you don't have any fucking lounge.
Lay off the damn coffee.
Oh, that's all it is. That's,
that's fascinating. That's amazing.
Is there anything that does that to
your dark fiber cystic Dick Cells.
And when you're a woman and you turn
about 40 your body is like a 64 Chevy you
must repair to in bitch. Like honestly,
since we're friends now, I tell you,
so when I turned 40 my cycle came on,
one day wouldn't go off.
So I had to go in now and they go,
I don't know the medical term,
but I know you're going to,
I know you're going to Google it.
They have to burn the inside
of your vagina. Oh good Lord.
They burnt my vagina,
Joe.
And they would beat box and for like
three weeks it was uh, it didn't hurt.
It was but woo woo woo boot. So
I called my doctor, I was like,
my pussy is singing.
Can you stop my pussy from saying it?
So it was like air or no, it was
healing. It was healing. Yes.
So in the healing it was popping and it
was, it sounded like it was making music.
What kind of healing was going on there?
I don't know, but it was like boom, boom,
boom. I could almost feel it in my
stomach and my doctor, no, I'm a comedian.
And I was like, I'm serious
dotting my puzzles, beat boxing.
So I go up there and
he said it was healing.
So essentially they had a cauterized,
is that the term? Something like that.
So you were bleeding so much
that they had to go in there.
They need to do two things.
They either burn it inside of you
or they give you a hit director.
Me and I didn't want to history,
so there was no other way to
stop the bleeding. No good.
It just break down
too crazy feeling that they burnt the
inside of you to cool everything off.
We had to stop the flow.
Yeah. That's crazy. Yeah.
God, this extra up things that women
have to worry about. Breast cancers.
One, like they say dudes get breast
cancer, but you know, I'm like,
oh y'all gotta worry about is dropped
penises that said, and then they, yeah,
south wieners.
Hmm. Yeah, but they fixed stat. They have.
Yeah, but they don't have anything
for broken titties and fucking vagina,
you know,
dry ass holes.
I know people, uh, people get
their vaginas tightened up.
I've heard that's unbelievably painful
though. Really go in there and fucking,
you know, a woman's had a few kids and
their vagina all blown out. They'll,
it doesn't blow it out. It's still got
some grip. You gotta use your on the Elmo.
Depends on the woman this,
I know what you're saying,
but there's realities about the shape of
the body, like about like stretch marks.
A lot of that's genetic. Some people
get stretch marks on people do not,
they don't have any dish. No,
probably got just crazy genes.
Some people they stretch way the fuck
out and have a kid and it all goes right
back into place. It's
amazing. And then some people,
one kid and they're Donesville the whole
thing. The whole package is just done.
Like someone just drove
a truck through a water
mine. My daughter in law
is like that. I was like,
don't have a baby because this baby
is gonna fuck up your finger. I said,
you young girls need to stop
fucking trying to be mamas.
Take your body and abused them.
How Fun.
Have a baby when you fucking in your
late thirties before about the drought.
Don't give them an opportunity
to fuck up your flat stomach.
But what if she wants a baby more than
a lot of shame and she's still trying to
wear that sexy shit. And I'm like, ah,
no booboo, take them home is not going
to work. You miss your opportunity.
I told you I don't let my fucking son
pregnant. No booboo take you.
Take that whole shit off.
Oh see I told you not to let my son get
you pregnant. Holy Shit. That's funny.
There was a thing in the news the other
day were ages 18 to 24 are twice as
likely to get vaginal
surgery than most women.
I guess it's really popular with the
young kids now to get the Barbie cut where
they chop off all the lips and everything.
So it's just the line,
you know like kind of like
surgery you mean? Yeah. Yeah.
To make you look less pussy.
It's, it's the porn that people
were trying to get the porn look,
you know like the perfect, that must
be exactly what is key is up crazy.
Everybody wanted daily what is vagina
lips call Labia Lavia everybody
read it.
I never say it
was going to kiss the stuff
that's coming out of it.
The gentleman out of it to catch an APP.
They have files but it's got to like
run down the sides. Meet curtains.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think it is pornography though.
Cause you think about like pornography
is so it's so bright and visual.
You know like if you got a camera and
you're, if you're having sex with someone,
you know there's a lot of stuff
going on, right? There's a,
their faces in your face kiss in,
you're touching each other.
But if you're watching a porn,
a lot of times it just showing
you like the insertion.
The show knew the Dick and the vagina
and the showing you the body parts is
showing you things moving and you're
concentrating on like this one particular
area and you could decide for
whatever reason like that that is,
that's what you got to focus on. Like
that needed to trim up your fucking yard.
He could clean your hedges.
So it looks like these videos.
Well you know a Joe, I got stomach
was sitting on my vagina is seen.
Is this the nineties maybe. I don't
know what's going on. Maybe I need some,
what is it called? Batman. Pussy too.
Yeah. I don't think you need
it. No, I don't need a job.
I mean nobody needs that.
Don't do that.
Plus some guys like it,
like Jim Norton,
he's always talking about
he loves big Pussy Lips.
It drives him crazy that when we get that
fixed and some some famous porn star,
I think her name was Houston.
She did something with her Vagina Lips.
Like she sold him or something like that.
Sally goofy that,
yeah,
there was something crazy cause I'm
trying to remember the story. She,
I think she got surgery then
she did something with it.
She was also one of the first
people to ever do a gang bang.
You remember still like the Houston.
We saw that.
She didn't hear it all the time when
crack first came out. Joe, come on Dad.
I mean in a porn again,
pay oh one of those giant ones.
Like 500 people like yeah,
she had 500 people have seen
this is the thing.
They say it's 500 people,
but it's really like 60 people and they
fuck her a bunch of times. They're like,
go through the line and they keep going
and you know, they act like a new guy.
I think some of them have actually gone.
I'm not into Poland. No, it was
Houston. She sold her labia for $50,000
like a silky blanket. What do
you, how long will it last?
$50,000 how long has it good for?
So then it's freezer somewhere.
He's probably had it dried out.
It's like he's like eating beef Jerky,
beef jerky for job. I need to call him.
Tell my daughter that she might like that.
Is there a I needed to,
she might like beef jerky.
Is there a photo of Said Lavia? No, I
don't want to see no sub labor. Yes.
I just don't understand. Is there a
before and after picture of her pussy?
If there's not,
that's reportedly,
yeah, I'm more for the women's of
trying to keep dales and you know,
I'm just one of vagina jacket. Just I
don't understand. I, it's gotta be that.
It's gotta be the porn. It's
gotta be, it's gotta be, I mean,
think about fake breasts. Fake breasts
are. So, you know what the other thing, I
was at a,
I did k rock the other day and um,
they brought up Korean women who
when the, uh, like Miss Korea,
you know Miss Korea, they look
exactly the same. Like pull up,
pull up, there's a v image. Oh No, no.
This is way crazy cause it's
all about plastic surgery.
They get a very specific type of look by
plastic surgery and it's super, super,
super common amongst Korean, all
of them. But that's what's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense because they
look exactly the same. So over the years,
like,
so how I think of how many look at this
plastic surgery blame for making all
Miss Korea contestants look alike.
Look at what these women look like.
They look exactly the same.
Like you could have photos of any one of
them doing something and then tell the
police and charged charge for the crime.
I mean, look at what they look like.
I mean, I don't like generalizations.
You say, oh, everybody looks the same.
Well maybe to you you're racist. Fuck
No. Those girls look exactly the same.
And what they're doing is apparently
they're going and getting a very specific
type of surgery. Uh, and they shaped
their face to a very specific way.
And they do it with their chins and they
do it with their eyes and they do it
with their noses. And when it's all
said and done, what I did from there,
very close. At least very close. I mean
really close when it's all said and done.
Their oldest. Exactly what site
that, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There's a lot of before and afters.
This is a real common problem.
Why wouldn't say common? I
wouldn't say a problem. Rather. Oh,
it's a cultural issue in Korea.
They're plastic surgery has run rampant.
Cause if you don't want to
have sex with your wife,
you sit in one of them over there.
And when was, I mean, oh, so if you
won't want to have sex with your husband,
yeah, your husband was here would be
exactly like he looked just like that.
Just seeing your husband.
Does he have any,
why don't you go out with your boyfriend?
And he sticks it in there and he re
realize it's like this one's tied,
this one's got that extra work done
down there and no means don't know.
This is not my wife was going on here
unless he thinks that she had something
done. But it's just a, it's a very strange
that they're all adopting this uniform.
Look, that's scary to me.
You know, that's a scary, uh,
there's before and after of wine.
You could still look at this.
She looks very actually fuck.
She needed,
they should do that.
Joe,
if you could tell him the big,
the big thing that they're getting is the,
what's been quoted as the anime.
I, if you look at the eyes,
they're very big and very, you know,
there's kind of stretched odis stress.
They are though,
they cut the Lids, they changed the lids.
They changed the shape of the lid. They,
they'd go in there and
they take too much pie,
slice out and pull that bitch
together and their eyes are like this.
That's what they do to people
when they get older too.
I know a dude who did that as eyes done,
like to get your eyes done and
all of sudden you're like this.
There's nothing like Clo.
A dude looking like a old ass woman
with plastic surgery isn't here.
Kenny Rogers. Have you seen
him lately? It is the creepiest
thing ever. He's like on a
commercial right now. Anything.
Kenny Rogers, terrifying.
Kenny Rogers is. Yeah. Well, do you
ever see when he looks like now?
No. Yeah. Let me think. You would
recognize him? Yeah. Poor guy.
He's pretty open about it. I think you
said conversations about or talked about.
I fucked up shit.
I mean,
you kind of have to talk about how you
fucked up when you look like this because
it's so obvious what Joan
Rivers had a lot of it. Yeah.
That's not a bad picture dude. In
that picture. He kind of looks normal,
but there's the pull it. That's a
bad picture. That's a bad picture.
Could get get a good one because there's
some good ones that are like really
shocking.
Just pull up Kenny Rogers,
bad plastic surgery and
you'll get some good ones.
I was on the beach the other day and
this dude caught a, a, a mantra rang,
you know what a Manta Ray is and he pulls
it in from the water and uh, there's,
it's in Malibu and it's all these rich
people that have houses there and they
think they can tell people what
to do for whatever reason. So, uh,
the dude had already released the Manta,
he caught it and released it. You know,
they were trying to catch fish and they
just caught this manta ray accidentally.
And so he, uh, he's releasing
it and this lady comes running.
Cause this other lady was like,
you know, they're doing this,
they're torturing that animal.
They pulled it out of the ocean and this
chick comes running to tell them what
to do. And when I tell you
that she looked like a monster,
like I am not exactly what she looked
like a monster. I mean this poor lady,
I felt bad.
Like she had done so much to herself.
It was like her face had been so pulled
back and the guys who are listening or
podcast fans,
the guys who caught the fish,
so they're probably listening
to it right now. They,
they were talking to me before.
So I assume if you know who you are,
what's up nice guys. Um, you
know, regular looking young,
tattooed up dudes who were out there
fishing and they caught this big ass man
array. But this lady came running and
when I saw her as she approached him,
I had a visual, I mean a
uh, like a visual visible.
Like I felt an a tangible like quiver.
Like I saw her,
I made the visual contact,
like my eyes hit her face and was like,
oh my whole fucked up here.
But did you do,
and not only that,
she's in this crazy ass fucking
multimillion dollar beach house. You know,
this,
those beach houses in Malibu or
ridiculous chicken was somebody who adds,
is not wide open wide. He's sleep.
He's probably just Xanax the fuck out.
Just trying to deal with her
and him and his own life.
He's a probably a mess too.
I don't know who he was or who she was,
but it was the arrogance of this crazy
lady running up these guys. She was guys,
throw it back,
throw it back.
Like you could keep a manta ray
and eat it if you want it to.
Nobody can stop you. And it's like you'd
beat look out there. That's the ocean.
Like that's a really fucking big,
it's idea that you'll have this guy on
the side of is going to do anything to
the population of the Manta rays.
Like that's not how animals die.
They die because of giant nets that they
pull amongst these huge boats and they,
they pulled them out of it.
That's what's over pop over fishing.
It's not a dude on the rocks pulling
some, but in her idea was that, you know,
in her mind she was going to tell this
dude with a mentor, but I felt so bad.
Manners are cute that they're
kind of different and unique
species. I I, oh yeah,
they're kind of cool. Yeah. But
you know, you, you ever had skate,
like get a restaurant. It's
delicious. What is skate?
Skate is a, it's a Manta Ray.
It's a type of rent. Wasn't that one that
was not the one that he caught. He got,
he was like a sting ray and had like one,
I don't know what kind of ran it was.
It was cool looking, but he
right. He let it go immediately.
He had already let it go when
this lady came running over,
but she just had such a monster
face that type monster faces,
so it's going to take this Manta
Ray and beat the hell out of you.
If you don't get on this beats,
they lose share face up.
They'd call the police so
fast. They probably have, I
don't know how they do it,
but you know like this Kenny
Rogers. That's a good, bad
picture of him. It's bad.
The one on the right, his eyes and his
nose is, he looks like he's high as fuck.
He might be in California.
That's not a good one though.
There's some other ones where it just
looks really awful. Whether there's other,
I've seen a one comparison. This one's
a good one too. Maybe. Yeah, that's it.
That's it.
Holy Fuck.
He like
that cannot be no Kenny
Rogers. It is. It is.
No,
that's him.
It changed the shape of his face and
it doesn't make you look better either.
It just makes you look different and not
in a good different, his eyes as wide.
You can't shoot that shit
in your face either. Man.
That thing that everyone's doing,
what they're putting filler in
their face and not just boating.
The black girls are putting
it in as they putting, uh, uh,
so many trends ginger's have died.
I'm serious stuff and things and there
was no, you haven't heard about it.
Google it. They was taking, people was
telling me he was giving them but shots,
but it was putting fucking corn,
oil, corn oil and the heirs. I know,
I know so many black
girls with fake booties.
That's a photo with some captions on
it. Yeah. When that shit harden up,
ain't nothing they can do with that crowd.
They can't go in and cut it out. No.
I don't know. I don't, I
wouldn't let nobody shoot. No,
no fucking home depot stuff and my booty
lips done back in the day are there.
There were scarred for life.
There's this poor lady that used to live
down the street from me and she had a,
like she talked to you and she had a
line like right here from here to here,
a straight line inside her lips from
where she had these artificial lips put in
and so when would talk to you
like the scar on her upper lip?
It was so distracting. It was like, what
did you do? You just see probably got it.
Lips like years, she won a
natural ones. Couldn't get it.
I always get compliments on
my lips. Yeah, Beautiful Lips.
Wait a minute.
They're beautiful.
Women want, they want those plump
juicy lips. You know, white women,
they'll go drastic measures
and I won't be as is now. Yeah,
they're getting them to weird.
Yeah. Should I show botched,
botched or it's all plastics.
I was watching one last night
where the woman got the,
the fake bud and it started to,
it popped or something like that and
started going into her leg and her inner
and stuff and they couldn't get it out
because it started growing with the
muscles and start attaching the muscles
so that they couldn't take it out and so
she just decided to get another one put
in there and then that one didn't take
because there was a, it was just all
fucked up a button plants and then,
then she could just flip them like she
would sit down and would flip it upside
down and stuff like that.
Okay.
Reversal. I saw it on, on
Facebook. I saw that lady,
she's just her as inside out and
it was a bad job and I was like,
as long as long as the ass is sticking,
the right way is not a bad job.
It was like a little flyer. How lower
your standards? Yeah, no, it's a bad job.
If you can flip it around. What have
you, a spokesperson for the surgery?
I don't know. I'm able when it
was turned the right way to ask.
It was nice and curvy when
it flipped over there,
like a plate there was
upside down and I asked,
could you imagine what it feels
like if he grabbed that thing?
Like you're wrestling with something
and it's like a fish is underneath the
surface.
It can't be no different
than sucking fate.
Geez. I gotta grab a cost by
at a strip club in Dayton,
Ohio and it felt just like
boobs on your butt by hers.
She got the really big ones that went
over like size of basketballs and so it
was just like jelly. Very Jelly. Ah, yeah.
Yeah. She probably went too
far. Yeah. That's what happens.
Everybody goes too far.
That's like some women can get breast
jobs and they just get a little,
a little bit of an enlargement
and it looks great. Yeah.
And then other women get crazy and they
get those basketballs put in and you're
like,
oh,
and you may have back problems
and they look stupid. It's stupid.
And they look Cleveland Sag. I'm
just going to keep it. What I got.
I'm going to keep the same man show.
I don't have time to be putting cutting
off my Libra yields. John Lilly. Oh,
your skin lift,
whatever you want to call it.
Cause that stuff going to dry your vagina.
You never going to have wet vagina
without having those lips. You dumb half.
Is that how it works?
So the lips like help.
What helps keeps the marsh was in there.
Moisture in the air.
We want to keep the shit,
wait. I'm learning a lot.
It's a lot of things I didn't
know. Yes. Um, I can't do all that.
I don't want to pull my neck
back. My eyes bet. I mean,
you know you're going to get old
shit is going to stop working.
That's why God gave you hand when
my husband ain't working no more.
I just unstick his balls
and we keep it moving.
We watched the news and go to
bed. You know what I mean? I
think, I think that also when people
are doing, they're early adopters,
you know what I'm saying?
Like the people that got the original
boob jobs like those they leaked and
there's silicone and the,
you know the poor people got sick and I
remember how many people got like Lupus
and all of these diseases from tick. I
knew a girl got lupus from her breast job,
she had a leaky breast
job and she got lupus.
Like she was all fucked up
or immune system was jacked,
but like they have a down where like,
you know, it's very few reactions.
It's a different feel to it.
Like you were talking about,
it's like a gummy bear boots. Yeah, they
feel like a real breasts. They feel like,
like really from real breasts and I think
that in the future and not so far away
either they're going to be able to
give you injections that make a woman's
breasts grow,
but they're going to be able to grow
natural gas. You know, I think if you,
if you don't have breasts and
shit is probably hereditary,
go back down the line.
You got to bet bunch of flat breasted
us and shit. He goes, most of have,
I remember when I it breaths and Mike,
so Mike,
I remember as a little girls
with him and he was like,
if you rub butter on your titties,
they wouldn't grow and
your ass they would grow.
So we went in fridgerator and took out
my momma butter and we just soaked out
chest in butter and so, and I'm
thinking that's why I got tennis today.
So ladies it don't spend your money at
the pleasant surge. Just buy some fucking,
I can't believe it's not butter.
Puts the two boobs in there and soak them
overnight and see if they grow in two
weeks. Not sure if that works. I
don't know either. But look at me.
I'm rocking a 44 double d
with grease up under it.
There's apparently, there's a lot
of people been working at this,
they've been trying to do
this for a long time and this,
there's a bunch of ways that
can kind of help a little bit,
but they're not exactly,
they're not really ready to grow tits yet,
but you know what?
Someone brought up the other
day that made a lot of sense.
They were saying that like when a woman,
a man becomes a woman,
when he becomes transgender
becomes a woman.
They start taking estrogen shots and
a lot of times they grow naturally.
They do.
I got a son who eats too much Mcdonald's
and he got nice size eight cups.
That's on the same note,
overweight.
He's overweight so they should gain
weight and grow tea. It might not work.
It might work, but it might not
work. What they're saying is
that they can give a man injections and
he starts growing like natural boobs.
Wouldn't they be able to give a
woman estrogen and would that make
probably is fuck us up cause
we already produced this crazy
women in here. Yeah,
right. It's an overflow.
You'll come home and he's been
cooking the cat, right? Yeah.
You don't want to do that.
There's a lot of fucking problems
apparently with silicone breast implants,
but particularly the silicone gel can
cause connective tissue or autoimmune
diseases such as rheumatoid arthritis and
Lupus, neurological disorders, cancer,
even new silicone related
diseases that didn't exist before.
Breast enhancement surgery.
So you got nice tits but
can't open your hands.
You can have some serious, but this
girl was all fucked up that had lupus.
She was a mess. You know like that's
a, those autoimmune diseases like that,
like Lupus and no joke,
you know,
is there, it didn't need plastic
surgery that you would get.
You know what?
I think man,
I think we're so close to them being able
to figure out how to do stuff without
it. Like I don't need plastic surgery.
I'm beautiful. Perfect as I am.
But I've had it. I had hair transplants
when I was younger. Obviously I just,
my hair was falling out and I
was trying to fight against it.
Had trends level doing got no hair.
No, I shave it. I should have shaved.
Yeah.
One way to look at it, why people
stop getting had transplant. Oh,
you gotta do is go to the hood and get
something to call a quick weave a quick
what you watch on my head, it's a
whole head of hair for $50. Listen,
that's not going to work with me. I do
Jujitsu like I'm getting, we don't get,
they don't get it. Like
this shit is not enough
to to not allow to get weaves.
It's just too pathetic.
That'd be shaking and shit
and we can tell this shake,
get that off near those shave the head.
I know a guy who works
at the lows in my area,
he got one and this fucking horrible.
It makes them look like a child molester.
You kill babies.
No,
but I don't like he creeps me out because
you know there's nothing like seeing
somebody that would a bad we've
when you were weed, right?
So you have a good one to him,
having a bad one is offensive to you.
It's the whole week.
Like when John Travolta,
where's his beautiful one and he goes
on the academy awards or you're like
that's a respectable leave. Yes. I mean
it's gotta look good. The problem is,
is glued to your head. Not
Anymore. This is sold in Sona.
Yeah, but if a dude's bald, like if you're
was bald, like I have stubble up here,
but it was all just, it was going, it
was gone. It was the party was over.
Then what happens is they take hair from
the back of your head and where it's
never going to fall out
and they move it to,
the joke was that it's like taking a bunch
of really healthy people and you move
into a neighborhood
where everybody's dying.
Cause that's what it's like when you, you
don't think about that? No, they stayed,
they stuck around there. The new residents
that like they, they, yeah, they grow,
but the old hair that used to be
there along with the transplants,
that's that shit all falls out of it.
Yeah.
So when you grow hair, what do it
look like? Do you look dot. No, no.
I mean I have have
enough hair to grow my hair out and not
look like I have cancer, but it's not,
it's pretty close. It was going,
it was on. It's getting thinner.
It was like cotton candy year.
It was getting old.
It was falling on more and more
and it was, it was annoying.
But he's still now just shave it.
Yeah they do. Well they do it now.
They do well what they
call single follicule.
So they'd take like one hair at a time.
They'll take it from
there and put it up there.
But the bottom line is you only have so
much hair back here and especially if
you go full Ronald Mcdonald's,
like if your, your hair goes bald,
like way back to the edge.
Imagine taking that little edge and
trying to populate your entire head.
Good luck.
You don't have enough hair.
So then they figured out how to clone
hair and that's what they're working on
now they're working on cloning hair,
but at the same time they're also
working on some other shit. Like that'll
just genetically there'll be able to
inject it and your skin and it will grow
hair like crazy.
They're pretty close to being able to
figure that out cause it's some sort of a
giant multi, multi billion dollar
industry. Dude's losing their hair.
But if I could give anybody any advice
from someone who's already shaved,
her head,
shave your fucking head.
I like
his hair too.
He was trying to hold onto this
like freeing and I don't
truly do not give a fuck.
Like it doesn't bother me at all anymore.
My hair used to fuck with me when it
was falling out because I was thinking
about shaving it, but I wasn't
sure if I could, you know,
I need you to do is just jump in and do
it. But once I did it I was like, Oh God.
Yeah. Once I did it though, it was
like, oh, this is so much better.
My husband used to have that kid in play,
fate in the middle and I was all like,
oh,
can you fucking get this? Got The Empty
Cup whole off the top of your head.
It looks like a bottle top opener.
What did you want him to do with it?
Cut The shit off. He was losing,
his hair was and it was like,
it would grow around the fake,
but it had a hole in the top.
So he was good until he went
on. What the fuck? You know,
looked like he was keeping a
little safe on top of his head.
We talked about the poor Jason Alexander
decided at like 50 something years old
to wear a toupee. Not a out of nowhere. I
don't know Jason, that was on the button.
You know what I'm saying? Seinfeld,
the show Seinfeld George from Seinfeld.
Do you ever watch Seinfeld?
No.
You're too busy shooting
people and fucking get it.
No,
my son feel he turned me onto Scifi.
A little is born that show and
then I watched, I was like,
this is a fucking great show
is a fucking great show. Yeah.
We spent many nights watching Seinfeld.
Do you know Richard Pryor story?
Yes.
Do you know his story of like of
growing up in a brothel? The whole deal,
but yeah,
I know your story's like five times more
crazy than Richard Pryor story. Yeah.
Yeah, I think so. It's pretty
close. I mean, Richard,
I suck no out. Oh, I didn't turn gay
for two weeks. I read Richard Book.
He turned gay for two weeks.
I only probably more than two weeks.
Probably more than two weeks.
It's more likely than he did some stuff.
I don't know.
I mean there's a different time too.
If you stop and think about like
what was going on in the 70s,
think about all the people that are
allegedly involved in gay shit. Well,
the brothel, right? Yeah. The Brian grew
up, it's prostitute house. Um, but you,
you know, you look at like, um,
allegedly David Bowie and Mick Jagger
went gay for awhile. You know, like,
um, what's his name from um, the
WHO, what the fuck is his name?
Not Roger Daltrey, the other guy. Jamie
towns and Pete Townsend.
Pete Townsend was gay for a while.
It is, it is shit. When you
and Hollywood is no more,
you don't the hell out of a Johnny.
You don't turn it inside out.
You don't stuck your foot in it.
You don't kick the cross the room.
You don't bake the pussy. You on a
beat you and bang the pussy. You don't,
you don't set it on fire. So
he's like, well, you know what,
I'm going to go away and play with
his Dick and see if I can just take,
takes a dick. Not that a gate
is trying to do something now.
I think that's what they do out here
just in Hollywood because in the Midwest
they just keep the same old bitch with
the beard who smoked cigarettes and tote
babies on her heels.
Um, maybe you got a good point. Yeah.
I think for a lot of dudes it probably
is that they probably want to just expand
their experiences.
Yeah. It's like getting fingers
putting as I tell you. Let me tell you.
So I went to, I did, I had to do
a hosting for ideal though. Party.
I'm not into deal dose. I don't want
to fudge. How'd you get this job?
They thought I was funny.
They came to a show.
So they like come hostile deal though.
Party. You have a Dildo party. Yes.
And women love this bitch.
They got traders, dad got that.
Do you know that they got the news
that the Dick with the suctions on it.
So you stick it to the toilet and
you just have sex with yourself.
When you finish,
you wrench it,
you rinse it off and put
it in the dishwasher or
whatever. Fuck you do with it.
So I host this deal to a party. So they
gave me this little thing and I said,
well what is this? She said, well go
home and spice up your relationship.
So I was like, oh my fucking relationship
could use some spices. I mean,
you've been married for 23 I
mean, what else? So I was like,
well what do I do with this? She was
like, this is bowed. Does. She said,
you take this fella,
you dusty his balls and you ball does.
But he came with a pink fell though.
So I go home with his bowel does
and I was like, oh your leg.
I got some bowel does and I pulled
out this felt them. I was like,
if you don't get that gay
ass kid away from my bottles,
he wouldn't participate. He wouldn't
have a, it was a fucking fat.
It was that families who the what the
fuck did you get balled does you're not
putting that shit on my walls because
it was pink. It would turn them off. No,
I think it was bowed. Does
period. My husband, I going
to do all that extra shit.
Why is pink universally a
girls color? I Love Pink. Huh?
What's not wrong with the color? But
I mean like, yeah, this is lighter.
It a pink lighter. It's a hello
kitty lighter. So it's definitely,
it grows lighter. That's
my light here. Exactly. So
a girl, we're just being
silly, but this is pink.
Like why is that color like a girl called?
Why is white?
It's because we never saw,
because when you grew up your mom put
you girls in a pink bedroom and bought
pink stuff and when you're a
boy I was boys were blue colors,
like their bedroom colors.
When you walk around with a baby,
that was a girl, but it looked like a
boy you put in pink. So people's like,
oh your little boy is cute. No,
she got on pink as a fucking girl.
Even though she looked like a boy,
but how did we figure that out though?
How do we figure out pill for girl?
Joe,
you got to ask the people who
started it follows Jesus Christ.
Questions. I don't know. Rosa
Park questions. Not rows apart.
Maybe Harriet Tubman. Of course.
I don't fucking know how they,
they came up with this shit.
I got a GED. Let's Google it.
Let's go with why. Why does the Color
Pink be associated with women? Yeah.
Probably causes a soft
collar because I think,
yeah it is, but isn't white as well.
White is my favorite color. Yeah.
A lot of people like white.
I have a white car.
It's good for now.
I want to be white because
I watched the leave it to beaver and
beaver. Mama was so fucking supportive.
I wanted that. Hate it from
my mom. She cooked every day.
You wasn't called bitches.
He wasn't shot at. I like to,
I want this bitch with my Mama,
so I wanted to be white.
Yeah, pink. They don't know. They
have no idea. They have no idea.
It's most commonly associated with
femininity. They don't have any idea why.
There's a bunch of speculation.
All different.
Pink was likely associated with
boy babies. As with girl babies.
It's a certain point in time. It was
just associated with babies. We've,
we had that picture a
member of was it? Uh, which,
which original PR? It was a theater.
Roosevelt dressed as a girl.
Oh yeah.
He was young.
They used to these boys pull that
picture up because it's so bizarre.
Do's dress with weak zone back in the
day. Yeah, but this is when they are
babies. They dressed him as a baby
when, as a girl, when he was a baby.
Why? They just did it back
then. They set a date.
Normal high heels were actually
made for men and stuff like that.
Like they used to dress. Really?
That's why they love him.
Now. Think about it.
You can take a gay man.
He do makeup and hair and dress way
better than normal, like a regular female.
Has that been Snopes?
We ever run that through Snopes.
Theodore Roosevelt supposedly.
No.
That's the lie that says though.
Okay. Let's see. Roosevelt
dressed as a girl, debunked
theater.
Let's see.
It wasn't always wow. It's true. Yeah,
that's true. What that, that the,
that isn't an actual, it's in the
Atlantic. The uh, the photographs, uh,
about girls or boys where
the dressing up as girls.
That's totally true.
He had shoulder length hair and a
hat trimmed with a Marabou feather,
but it not because he was a gender bender.
Um,
the unexpected childhood
look as a reminder that our
cultural norms about gender
specific clothing for children
are a surprisingly recent
historical development.
Wow. That has interesting,
man. It was 1884.
He was two and a half years old and boys
wore dresses until age six or seven,
which was also the time of
their first haircut. Wow.
That's so weird.
Franklins outfit was considered
gender neutral. So that outfit,
pull that outfit up again. That outfit
was considered gender neutral at the time.
What outfit? The outfit
that he was wearing where we
think it looks like a girl.
Okay.
Look at that. That's, that was gender
neutral. That was a girl with you though.
Yeah. Look at his little
booty shoe and his, his hair.
They didn't cut your hair except
like most aisle across your face. So
see where you're going.
You still look like that.
That's out in the smithsonian.com
also that all this,
they talk about all the pink and blue.
Really detail.
Yes.
That is that detailed.
I mean for the Google between pink
and blue. I personal give a fuck,
but I'm learning a lot here.
I mean that's fascinating to me. It's
fun. It's absolutely fascinating to me.
I was watching Fox News.
We talked about this before,
about those women than on Fox
News. No, not because I believe in.
I just cause it's fascinating.
I love,
I love people that are convinced of
anything. I want to be convinced of God.
I'll watch religious shows. I like
people that convinced there is no god.
I watch atheist shows.
I like watching people convince just to
study their patterns, but I'm watching.
Fox News is always fascinating to me
because it's like this weird look into
another world that I don't ever hang out
in. You know, I don't know these people,
but these women are so hot
and they're there, so leggy.
If someone's naked legs going
on and I was thinking it,
if a man dress like the on TV,
it would be a fucking shit.
It was be a sin like you would that if
a guy dressed even remotely like one of
those women on television, it would
be front page news. It'd be like,
what the fuck has society fallen too?
So if a man came in
with like mail ups show,
so I mean really tight.
Yeah, but that's not, see shorts are one
thing. These women, there's no short,
there's no fancy.
You have to pull down.
You just lift their skirt
up and start fucking, it's
right there. Their vagina is,
is a tiny little piece of
cloth there on Fox. These are,
they have tiny little dresses on
what?
Oh,
that's what make people tune in and you
flipping through the channel and you see
a signal. Holy Fuck. Exactly.
You know you're going to stop and you'll
care what they're saying. I mean, look,
you're Sarah Paler.
They think she's fucking hot.
Well, she was harder back in the
day. She was prettier. She's,
she's starting to hit the wall and
now, now it's getting weird. Not,
but if you thought she was hot when she
was running for president and like six
years ago, whatever it was, that would
be kind of, she was Kinda hot back then,
you know, like a power thing
also, I think maybe, well,
it was a book and God bless America
sort of a thing, son. She's a little,
first of all, she's a rugged
outdoorsman. Lives in Alaska. Okay.
Woman's been honor her whole
life and she's kind of pretty,
well, you know what she
would do? Allegedly,
they would shoot a Caribou
and then they would, uh,
call her for a photo op and she would,
they would, she would get out of her car,
they'd hand her, the gun should
stand down there over the body.
They take a photo and she'd hop back in
the car and drive off pick. They would,
uh, they would shoot an
animal just specifically to
make her a little a hunter.
I know what a care bill is. You know what,
to calculate a deer. Yeah. It's rainbow.
A reindeer rather, I guess that, but
oh fuck yeah. That's what a Caribou is.
You know, like when Santa has those
reindeer, that's those are Caribou.
So in the deer family lose
income to the ghetto? No, no,
they barely come to Alaska. You've got
to go find it them there. Uh, you know,
we didn't believe Randy laying on your
house if you was getting gift than
somebody showed up. It was a
fucking Santa Claus with a pit bull.
Did you ever teach your kids about
Santa Claus or did you just, I told him
it's all bullshit.
I tell you,
when I moved in my white neighborhood,
I'm in,
I'm in Walmart one day and my son was
talking about getting something for
Christmas. He was talking to my son. I
was like, it ain't no fucking Santa. Okay,
just tell me what you want. And I buy
was what? How old was he at the time?
He probably was like 10. So a lady, a
white lady in, I like, how dare you,
not saying it's a seven. I was like,
bitch, he ain't brought me no money.
My own business white woman.
Fuck is you talking about you
want my son to grow up in bleed?
Some nice fat chubby white dude's just
going to show up and leave Torro. Oh,
he got a fucking chimney.
I got an electric flight place.
How the fuck are you gonna
get in my house? Exactly.
How the fuck is he going to get? We'll
get in my house. So she was like, don't,
don't not tell kids is not Samhsa.
I put up a tree because it's cute.
Isn't that funny?
That you have to like that has to be told.
That's a lie that we all agree.
You have to tell children.
It's Easter bunny or the tooth fairy.
You would catch.
I'll catch my stepdad and now taking my
fucking tooth and put $5 up on there and
when I wake up, my Mama want to
borrow to $5 so she can get high. Wow.
So I'm like all these teeth, you laws
and then fucking to fair. Come on,
leave you no money. Yeah. The
tooth fairies. The weirdest one.
What is the Easter bunny tooth
fairy Santa Claus was the other one.
Um, Easter bunny. Tooth fairy.
Santa Claus Secretary's Day
secretary there.
That's a failed attempt to my
mother in law won't, won't, uh,
won't celebrate Halloween because she's
Super Christian and as the devil's
birthday, Whoa, you
mother-in-law says, yeah,
like don't buy mess his demons and maximum
like shit the fuck up and by masters
DNA and masks. Well what if it's
a mask of like Tokyo or something?
It's a demon. You shouldn't have. You
shouldn't like my mother. A lot of like,
you shouldn't have like,
you know how people have those fat
LF loons and shit on they flow.
You can have that because
they care is deans hold up
um, fat elephants on their floor
carry demons. What? You know,
you know how you go and people
having to have those uh,
those glass elephant shit and
tigers laying on the floor.
You been at black houses with yeah, the
black leather couch and like a sculpture.
Yeah. That she didn't have
those. No, not where I'm on in.
She say that stuff carries Dino's,
she's super say golf truth carry demons.
Sh the, the, I don't know where she
gets a shit for. Only read that one.
That's a tough one. Like you know,
someone makes a sculpture like that.
The Eagle sculpture in San Francisco,
I grew up,
I grew up in like my
momma had a Jesus pitches.
Every black household had a Jesus
Christ and I'm all of the king pitcher.
You wasn't black if you didn't have
no fucking two pitches in your house.
How come nobody knows who Rosa Parks's.
Nobody knows what she looks like.
I got this
photo of Rosa Parks Mugshot up on the
wall and everybody thinks that it's a
Asian lady. I thought she
was. I just don't understand.
I don't, I don't know how. That's
not a famous person. How's that?
Not a famous person.
It's a fee as persons who she was,
but how's it not like recognizable like
Martin Luther King Recognizable Malcolm
x recognizable. If you saw his
photo galleries, is that what it is?
She's probably by ratio.
Oh, for sure. Yeah.
She's definitely biracial
by the her coloration,
but I don't know. Just probably
better instead of doing that.
Well, you could do that, but it's hard
to zoom in on that. Yeah, there you go.
That's what Rosa parks look like.
Nobody knows.
So she was a lady that said
no. She said, fuck this.
I'm sitting right here, became
fit boy, they fucking to move.
She looked white. Nobody asked
her to move, but they say x. Dot.
I think in that at that time it's like
she was the tipping point, you know,
people date. Imagine,
imagine when they had whites,
only fountains and shit.
My daddy always talked about that shit.
He passed about three years ago when I
brought him to Indianapolis to live with
me. And my daddy really never lived
around white people. So when my son,
all his friends was white. So my data
was say like Pat, you got to get Gary.
He had that pulling them a little cracker
keys on his motorcycle and I'm like,
damn, ain't nobody say that shit anymore.
He was, he had a slave mentality.
Well,
if you stop and thought yeah,
about it for a second,
like how,
how recent slavery was a really kind
of freaks you out because that was 1865
they made slavery legal. That
is not that long ago. No,
that is not that long ago. That is
weird. That's less than 200 years.
Stop. And think about that.
1865 that's not that long ago.
If you lived to be a hundred years, if
you, if you're a hundred years old today.
Okay. And that means that
in 1914 you were born, okay.
If you were born in 1914 a
hundred years before that,
1814 slavery's legal as fuck.
So that's like two generations, you
know, grandfather to father to grant his,
you know like if you go back like
two more generations before that,
that's not that many people.
That's like a guy has give a woman,
gives birth to a child, the child gets
raised, has children of his own and then,
and maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe
are alive like the, the patterns of
people that are live birth to death,
birth to death. There's only three,
three generations of birth to death.
And you got, I mean, not a guy
giving birth, you know, I'm,
I'm a woman giving birth to her own child
and him giving birth to his own child,
but a person living from birth to death,
the next pink person being born,
birth to death. There's only three that's
not that long. And that was buying.
People could just buy them
and take them. You could fuck
them and you could kill them.
You can do whatever you want. And
there wasn't any laws. They were yours.
They were your property.
Yeah.
They would just tell you if you beat
him to tell you not to beat him as much.
And I don't fucking know. I wasn't
around, but I couldn't imagine.
Could you even imagine, can you imagine
owning a person in your backyard?
What's fucked is when you hear this,
just as much slavery today as there
was during during 1865 if you like,
looked at the world,
the whole world as far as the numbers,
six slave shit going on with the younger
kids. I heard a lot of those kids,
the it,
well,
I will say I liked it,
but I don't think those kids
like he wouldn't let me go home.
Of course they don't like it.
Imagine that someone would justify it.
Sex Slavery, like, look, look, look.
This is other problems in the world.
Can we have an energy problem?
This global warming.
That's probably,
that's how they look at it and look,
you had to ban your momma didn't
have shit. Come on over here.
It's like a few deek.
Let me feed you.
Well, you made it work. You you,
you were like a person who was,
I mean you a sec.
It's actually molested.
If you are having sex with a man in his
twenties and you're 14 or you were 12 at
the time when it first started,
you're being sexually molested.
You made it work, but it was good.
Sexually molested. He was horrible.
Yeah. Yeah. Just didn't give him credit
for that, but it was good. And employed.
Unemployed black means a can.
Fuck.
That's all my husband.
No lists I listening to.
But if we're going to see photos of this,
don't you want us,
cause I really want to see when you're
just walking. No, no, no, no, no bro.
They coming to your
house to go to jail. You
know what he means is a 12 year old. That
looks like a grown woman. I want to see,
do you have boobs or are you holding
like a teddy bear and looking back at 16
yeah. Wow. Yeah, that'll work. Let me
see if I can get this fucking phone.
I can show you me at 16 you
know what was crazy? I was at,
that was a drug deal on his pitches.
So my daughter was like,
oh you don't look like I expected
you to look. And I was like,
well what do you expect? You
know, gold teeth. And I was like,
I wasn't fucking up my teeth cause
you fucking crazy. You don't know.
It was the most, that was the biggest
scam in the ghetto. Those. Dennis,
we're putting teeth go teeth on those
cricket as black people t when I shouldn't
say,
hey dude,
take this dope money and get some braces
first before you fucking Crowley's both.
Before you cram these goals
on these raggedy ass tea.
So you made a club and it's my fault.
Got Teeth in his map.
Look like a Perato you like what the fuck?
Okay,
explain that to me
cause I'm white.
What is it about gold teeth?
It's not about goatee. Black
people are flashy. We like go.
We like shit this shine.
Why is that?
Because we want to stand out and I tell
you, we wait, wait, wait black people.
We want you to know we
got it. Ah, because you really, you come
from not having it. So when you get it,
you tell the fucking road.
Cause I was just telling my friend,
I said what is it with black people that
are run out and buy buy thousand dollar
jeans.
It you fucking got a food stamp card
but your pocket book costs $800.
You know,
you gotta fucking,
you gotta get a name brand purse or you
get a knock off name brand purse for
$200 and in any fucking real
leather and it don't have no value.
Just so people can say,
I'm told him Michael Cole,
I'm talking a little bit on what we know
is not a little bit torn because you're
fucking cause raggedy and your teeth
this cricket and you got a band,
we've bitched and you got a lot of kids
behind you. You don't buy Louis Tom.
If you're fucking, you got four or
five kids that don't work like that.
Don't bad start at two grand.
But Louis Vuitton,
it's like not like a Ferrari.
Like if you get a fake Louis Vuitton, what
happens? It doesn't hold shit, you know?
No, she is foam and they act like
it's real. You know what I mean?
Like if you have a fake Ferrari, you know
you're not driving Ferraris for ours,
they fall apart. The
person's fall apart. Very
China. They're making fake Ferrari's
right now and a God damn assembly line.
I bet this dude's out there
that have fake Ferrari's.
Don't even know they have fake Ferrari's.
It's probably totally possible.
I never heard him to thank for Roger,
but I know by some fake bags and
want to be flashy and you know,
and I was going to get a gold
grill when I was a drug dealer,
but I had a friend was like,
you're not always going to do this
shit and you have really nice teeth,
so why would you fuck them up?
So if you did get gold teeth, they have
to like chip out the outside of it. Yeah.
No they do. They, they, what they do is
they, my brother had beautiful teeth.
I mean,
he could've did a fucking
Colgate commercial and he
went and got a goal and they,
they,
they fucking moved his front teeth and
put a gap there so they can push the goal
up. And he decided, I
don't like this shit.
This country has brother my put a pin
in his mouth and rip the goal off his
teeth.
Wow.
About,
no, it didn't bleed. He was
just my brother. He'll build it.
I until I got two brothers with the
same name and that they're not twin.
The name is Anthony and Tony and
that they real fucking night.
And you know what Joe,
I didn't even know that.
I didn't even recognize that
until my house. Like, Pat,
what are your brothers have
the same night. I was like,
my fucking brother's don't have to say
that. My name is Tony. He was like, Pat,
that's the same. That's, Oh, what
the fuck? That is the same name.
No one else has the same name. John and
Jack. What did they not John and Jay.
John F. Kennedy was Jack Kennedy. Yeah.
John F. Kennedy was Jack. They called him
Jack Kennedy. That's it makes no sense.
It's one of the weirdest ones.
That's a weird one to weird abbreviation,
but that abbreviation is
not always used. Like, um,
I know a Jack that was born Jack, like
on his birth certificate it says Jack,
but John is the, you know the nickname
of John Has Jack, is it j? O? H? N?
I don't know. It's a good question.
You're at 16. This photograph.
Here's
why. That was one of a kind.
Let me see that. That's you.
At 16 would him and that's the dude.
That's a grown ass man. I had the baby by.
Wow. That's crazy. That's
the dude that shot you.
That's the dude who shot me. Well, this
is hard to see because it's kind of a,
an old picture. Yeah, but what did you do?
His phone.
How'd you shoot this phone?
I broke the in Lowe's at the
hardware store. Yeah. Is that a note?
Yeah, that's a no. Those are great,
aren't they? Yeah. For old people like me,
who wants to see those are great for
going online though. Looking at web pages,
you can't beat it. You can't beat it
for that. So here's me as a drug dealer.
Oh, I'll show you my kids. Unfortunately.
This is a podcast that people listen to.
I'm showing it to you. I know, I know,
but I'm saying that I wish
that everybody who listens,
it could get out a photograph with us.
That's your kids right here. That's me.
Like 16 wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
You at 16 with two kids and one
of them looks like it's six.
I'm not even fucking around.
That's crazy.
That's a child with children chow.
It's your crazy life. Miss Pat.
Yes I did. How did you, how did
you choose? The name is pat.
How'd you go with Miss Pat?
Because I was going to name myself rabbit,
but that was too close to my drug in life.
Right.
And so I didn't want him to
come to the stage ram it.
They're just too fucking blind.
Ah.
Sounds like, Ooh. Can I call my seven?
At that time when I started being
a comedian, I still had them,
the little vending business at the
Donaldson and all my daughter school
classmate works for me. So everybody
called me Miss Pat. So I was like,
where did it make people respect
me, Miss Pat? So I was like, okay,
the key is naming. That's
a good one. I like Miss
[inaudible]. My name is Patricia.
Very well. It's very easy
to remember too. And it's,
it's unique to you and you
automatically know on black.
It could be Jay, like an Asian. No.
You automatically know Miss Pat.
That could be an Asian,
a crazy Asian chicken wears tight
leather clothes or a gay Asian dude.
No, I've walked up on people
like him in mainstream ones.
Things like who performed the
night? He was like, Miss Pat,
miss pat gotta be black. It's got to be
some Dev jam and I'm standing. I'm like,
no bitch.
The fuck is you talking about white
boy with your cat jokes with your cat.
Why did he catch up?
Because like you'll go to amazing club.
Are you fucking hear his cat jokes?
I'm like,
don't you fucking white boys rob a bank
so you can be more fucking interesting.
You gift that basters gifted bastards.
Yeah. You had a privileged privilege.
Basters I don't want to hear your cat.
You don't want to fucking change
your little box. Hey, come on.
Let's rob a grocery store bit so we
can eat. Let's do some real life shit.
What kind of cat jokes are you here? Is
this Indianapolis catch no. Everywhere.
Joe
and I don't fucking tell a cat joke
in from it. Fucking drives my vagina.
Go onstage at the UCB. What the fuck is
that? That's the hipster club. That's it.
Do it. Do is wear cardigans
and the, they all have cats.
No, I have cute two cats. You do?
I have two cats.
Two dogs and 24 chickens.
What a fuck do you live in
California with chickens? I live.
I got to tell you my chicken shout Joe.
You got the chicken store? Yeah, I have.
My Mama had one chicken in the back.
She had a lot of them,
but she eventually killed them out.
So I'm telling you to choose.
So we,
when my life was so bad,
I would go outside every day and just
tell this chicken everything, you know,
cuckoo.
My Momma ain't shooting at us.
It was cool. Was cool.
Cool. Oh fucking hate it.
Then my mom was so I would talk
to this chicken and you know,
chicken walking around
eating shit off the ground.
I really thought he was concerned and
was listening to me. So how does Lee,
I come home from school and
this bitch got my chicken,
my only friend that was listened to my
pain by the neck and getting ready to
kill him and a chicken as is big and I'm
looking at it chicken and he looked at
me and I'm like, Nigga, you snitch on
me and she don't fucking kill me neck.
And she killed that chicken
and she made me eat it.
Wow. That was well you know that's
what a lot of people have chickens for.
They kill them and eat them.
I didn't know.
I made friends with it so I,
that's why I don't have
a chicken for a pet.
I don't have a doubt because I had a
dog named pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop,
pop, pop, Kukula pup. I ice
a lot of fuck out of him.
So we're running right and got reelected.
Pup got upset about the election,
I assume and jumped out the back porch
with a change on the neck in fucking hung
herself.
Wow.
That's why I won't vote Republican
because I run a and kill my fucking die.
Reagan
moved to Canada because of George Bush.
Really?
I thought about that shit when he read
one. When he won in 2004 I was like,
this is, this is a crazy place to live.
I've got to get out of here. When he won,
we won.
I was seriously thinking about going to
Vancouver and that was on TV at the time.
I was like,
I would have been hard for me to move to
Canada and still come back and do fear
factor, but I was like, this is not
good. This is insane place to live.
We've got to get out of
here. I was totally convinced
we had to get out of here.
Oh Shit. Going to try to get all my
friends moved to Vancouver to, yeah,
they all say they want to do shit for us,
but in the end we are going
to get fucked up by them.
They don't give a fuck about us.
They just want to buy nice meals,
nice suits and do the fuck
they want to do. I wonder,
people don't care about people anymore.
When I was little Joe,
you could go to the black church and
eat on Sunday for free for years until
Ronald Reagan got reelected.
I'm telling you,
he fucked us up because after that they
started charging $5 for the meal and I
haven't, I haven't been back to the
church since five bucks seems reasonable,
but not when you live where I
fucking live in the 80s right? Oh,
those was five bucks
once a month, right?
That was like $10 right?
Probably 20 in my neighborhood when
we didn't even eat fucking fruit.
We ate beans every fucking day.
But don't you think they like times
are tough and prices for things are
expensive and people would,
do you really think that people
don't care about people anymore?
No, they don't. They don't
shoot you out though.
If you my friend,
you might fucking frame.
All right.
Are We fucking friends or what?
We're not fucking free. I mean,
you said my fucking friend.
You Scad of words. I am. Yeah.
You my friend. You're my friend
and I'll do anything for you.
I'm not a too faced that type bitch.
I'm down with you,
but people would say they down
with you to get what you got so
you could say that about his business
in this bit. This is a cut throat.
This is almost like getting
a drive by in the hood.
I disagree. You know
why? Why are you here?
Then you here because we want to help you.
We found that we've heard about you,
but this is the business.
This business is right.
I'm not saying everybody's like that.
This business is going on right now in
this room is this business and in this
business we're just trying to
help you so that's bullshit.
What does you can find?
No, you can find it.
Those people, this is this. This is
my thoughts on this business. Yeah,
you can find those
people in this business,
but you could find
those people everywhere.
You could also find people that are nice.
Yes.
I really believe people,
there's more nice people than people
give credit for because the negative
instances stand out. It's like
when people talk about like online,
like commenters on youtube
and shit like that.
Think about what percentage of people
that is like everyone's like if it was a
perfect example that society is doomed.
Go read.
Like I was reading something about
Floyd Mayweather the other day.
Floyd Mayweather took a picture with
his new girlfriend and they'll fucking
comments were soap.
I think that is even when you get on
youtube but you get up and you talk about
Beyonce baby hair. I was
like, these people are human.
Like people will say shit to me and act
like I did a podcast and I talked about
putting drugs in my baby panties and
everybody was at the time was tween you to
get me on. So this dude was like, oh,
why would you want her own Joe rugged
when she put drugs in my baby pen. I said,
hold on bitch.
I was 15 years old at the time.
Have you thought about where I was
in my life at that time? I said,
plus don't judge me bitch. You probably
like fucking frozen Q commas up yo ass.
But nobody's coming over your house
trying to pull it frozen cube commas out
your ass.
I'm not judging you because you like,
cause
if he doesn't feel frozen cucumber,
I mean when people, people do, they write
ugly stuff. Sometime I look at it, they
don't have to deal with you face to face.
See that's not a normal way
to communicate with people.
You people get a free shot
at you like you're miss pat.
You know you're on the Internet,
you're on a video,
they see it and they can just start
talking shit for free and more than one.
It's not one on one.
Like if you were doing that in a room,
our knock,
they fucking ass.
Listen,
if you're in a room,
like say if you were in a
room and you're talking to me,
and then someone who is a youtube commoner
was sitting right there and listening
to you talk,
you see,
you see someone who would say
something awful about you on Youtube.
If they were sitting right next to you,
they wouldn't say, they wouldn't say shit.
Yeah, they wouldn't say shit.
And if they did say shift,
they did say something rude. He'd be
like, where the fuck are you coming from?
Why are you coming up with it? I'm not,
first of all, I'm not talking about you.
I'm not talking to you. It doesn't concern
you. So why you making some sort of,
and then you'd have a conversation with
that person and they would be shown to
be retarded and then it would be done,
but they could just leave it on youtube.
That comment is permanent.
Yes. This moron statement,
that's not supposed to happen in nature.
It's just not.
When you think about how many people
that is though, that's a small,
what percentage of the people
comments on youtube videos?
Is it even 1% yeah,
but what is the number?
I mean isn't one 10th of 1% is it even
that you could just look at the likes and
dislikes of every video on that? Pretty
much sums it up. Yeah. Likes and dislikes.
It's pretty easy, but comments
sometimes they're interesting.
Sometimes they're engaged,
like we talked about that with Lewis
from unbox therapy that sometimes he gets
people that are like really knowledgeable
and are interesting and they have
discussions the in the Commons,
but it's the shit like on Floyd Bay where
they're talking about his girlfriend.
I was like, whoa. Not
just jealous, hateful.
And they're also,
they're there.
They're giving in to their situation.
They're giving in to that this guy is
rich and famous and a superstar and
successful and I am less,
I will never be in his position,
so I want to take free shots of him.
I'm going to throw away
rocks.
They would never say that in his face.
Looks like when they was going
around saying columby say baby. Yeah.
Who the fuck are you to tell it to be and
say that baby is more Richard than all
you motherfuckers. I know if that
made me want to have nappy hair,
her parents were on having that baby hair
was nappy or whatever you want to call
it. She still look better
than y'all fucking baby. Who
was born on Medicaid Bitch?
Well, again, if the baby
wasn't born on Medicaid,
your argument is it valid and then you
don't know what the fuck you talking.
Exactly. I mean, people pick at
people. They don't realize that you,
when you say stuff like that,
they can hear it.
Well, it's just, it's stupid. It's
just stupid. It's a, it's, it's a,
it's a situation that's
never supposed to happen.
Human beings are supposed to
communicate with each other.
They're not supposed to just communicate.
And when you just communicate,
no one's there.
And you could just say whatever you want.
There's no repercussions.
You're in an echo chamber.
You don't even have the fucking name
that you have. Like your, your 69 eat me.
That's your youtube name,
you know.
So 69 eat me has all these things that
they say and they can say fucked up shit
on every video they find online.
They're not even a real person.
And they could have 20 of those names.
They could do whatever want they got.
Situation
doesn't exist in nature, but it
doesn't mean that people are fucked up.
It means that there's an avenue for
fucked up people to express themselves.
It didn't exist before and
there's evidence of that.
I had a fat girl one time I was on Bob
and Tom and I said some stuff like,
oh my [inaudible] Dadada, you know,
I don't like being fat or fat.
Girls like to eat all the time. So this
lady sent me like all along as EMA,
how dare you talk about the fat girl and
why is you on their clansmen show with
them? White Dude. Hey you
did and fat girls all six.
And she sent me all these fucking coupons.
Then she sent me all these fucking a
little things for clothes or fat girls all
on was fucking leper and I don't put
on no leopard anyway and bird tigered.
That's what fed girls
were lepers in Tongan.
They want him to look like
animals so you can shoot it.
I saw
why they always were leopard. You look
at line Brian and national stores,
they always fuck everything is animal
print. I think they trying to kill us.
I don't want to shit, I went black.
Okay, big. Okay. So look at big girl,
big girl. I'm telling you did. She
sent me to his jumper and she was like,
big girls are sexy and so I was going
to tear her ass up and my husband talked
me out of it.
Well you need to do is you need to write
a bit about big girls and I do have a
baby. You have a bit about that? Yeah.
You'd need, I need to hear that bit. Yeah,
true.
I told girl leopard titties
everything. Teigel and animals and
Zebra. Zebra pants. Why is that?
I don't know why they think we want
to look like a bear or some shit.
I say
that is a weird thing.
Maybe it's like an attempt,
an appeal at the animalistic active.
I don't buy Leopard
panties. I don't. Okay.
Want to see my big [inaudible] walk around
or leopard pants and no leopard bra.
And then I got stomach
hanging over the front of it.
And you don't want to see
that shit. No, no. I don't buy
like, like Valentine's Day.
Look, Valentine's Day. It always
are pink and red leper, lingerie,
lingerie for fat girls. I'm
not putting myself in that
shit. I'm, I'm not doing it.
No lingerie
tee shirt. Okay. I'm with my
panties on. I'll be angry at me. Oh,
I'm passing lingerie party when I lost
my virginity and the graveyard, I'm done.
Lingerie is over. No senior husband
lose all this weight and go vegan.
Does that make you want to do
anything? Yeah, but I'm lazy.
You got to know your boundaries.
I'm like, I need a sponsor. Y'All
lazy cause you hustle.
Awesome. My ass off. So how was that?
Everybody got their one thing that
they can accomplish, read off.
And that for me is losing without,
I just lost 30 pounds on
nutrisystem and so you know what?
I don't have $300 this month.
I quit.
That's fucking nutrisystem
food is still at the house.
I went straight to chick filet. What
is nutrisystem? How's that work?
They send you like healthy foods and
meals and it works if you can afford it.
And I could afford, I think
weight watchers. Have you
ever tried weight watchers?
I can't count and I'll fucking points.
I'm busy. Nobody haven't. Yeah,
I've got a GED. I can't keep up with
that kind of shit. I just move my knees.
I just move my knees
and her four kids ain't,
I ain't got time to be killing shit.
I can't do that.
I need some you can pop in a microwave,
eat it and they ain't
gone about your business.
Yeah. But if you had like,
this is what I believe,
I believe that you're going to be very
successful. That's what I believe.
Absolutely. You're going to have crazy,
crazy money. And uh, when you do,
are you going to get like
a private chat trying
to cook you like healthy meals and then
I'm a ring a bell
thousand calories.
Miss Pat shrivel up or are we going to
see miss pat say thank you very much.
The healthy meal and you shut your door
and bolt it and then pull a drawer out
from underneath your bed and
you start stacking cakes.
Snickers bars.
No,
I can get half of my
sixth grade figure back.
Hell had just fun. I used to
be 140 pounds. Wow. Oh God.
And Nice round titties and both nipples.
That was the good old days.
Yes. Slowly work your way back
to that. We can make this happen.
What is he going to do?
Is eat healthy? It does. You
know, I was eating healthy.
Then I moved my niece, my
niece was homeless with four
keys. She's 23 years old.
So I said, okay. I raised her for 10 years
and Mama can't make a fucked up. I like,
so I went home for Christmas,
I fucking got my niece for kids
and I just started back eating.
I was so stressed out. I mean, how do
you bring five people into your house?
Kids literally had no shoes, no
nothing. And I took everything.
I had to get these kids back together.
I mean these kids were so behind on these.
They shot, her four year old was
getting newborn shots. Oh my God.
So I had, I mean I think that that
brought on a lot of stress and I was like,
fuck it.
I'm just gonna
start making sure, I'm sure.
Yeah, stress is a fucker.
And when you hit stress,
the first thing you do when
you hit like a real bad patch,
just to go back to whatever comforts
you. Yeah. For some people it's food.
For some people at cigarettes, for
some people it's booze, you know,
and I need to lose weight. Oh my God, I
just lost a hundred pounds. We'll do Liz.
Jess, too funny. We got to
keep you healthy. Yeah, right.
We got to keep you healthy.
I won't drop dead. When are you back
here again? We've got to do this again.
We ran out of time. We just have
three hours. Oh, we did? Yup. Fuck.
I feel like I've been here for 30 minutes.
Crazy.
Just flew bar three hours is over. I
don't know. Whenever you call for me, I'm,
you've got an open invitation. Anytime
you want to come on. Anytime anything.
Can I promote my website please?
Ya'll please ya'll my Twitter comedian.
Ms. Peck Comedian is pat Facebook.
Yeah.
Comedienne like as in girl,
comedian or a very controversial thing,
like a lot of comedian female comedians
and just said, I'm a fucking comedian.
I'm not a comedian.
Well, I asked my friend who had
a college degree, I was like, oh,
I need you to spell comedian,
the girl. Right. So she goes to,
the thing is if you just type in m s p a
comes up MSP 80 and I have a Instagram,
Facebook and my website is
Miss Pat Comedy, Ms Pac,
comedy.com pet company.com.
I want to do a couple of
days at Toledo, Ohio. Uh,
August 8th through ninth at laughs.
I'd be at the funny bone one night only.
So it's very important that
you come out to the funny bone.
I want to show them that I have some
fans which funnybone. Um, Atlanta.
Hell No. It's the a date date,
date. Date Fund about, yeah.
Funny is a good spot.
We ain't got no funny bone in Atlanta.
We got to impart on you. They don't
book me yet. Funny Bone is Columbus.
Columbus for now.
Yeah.
And the day I'm in Dayton and [inaudible]
August 28th through the 31st Chicago,
Chicago,
great room and Oklahoma City,
Oklahoma City.
I'd be there September the 10th
through the 13th at the loony beans.
It's all this on your website.
All of this is on my website.
Pat comedy.com Ms Pat, comedy.com. Thank
you so much. This was really a lot of fun.
I really,
really drunk you to the fans who got me
here and I want to thank my friend Avery
at mortise comedy joint cause
he told me three years ago,
he said if you get on Joe Rogan's
some shit might happen. And I said,
who the fuck is Joe?
And I'm here.
Beautiful every made it real.
Avery diligent at Marty's coming to
jump in and give a big shout out to uh,
Randy who's helping me with a project
in India. That was a beautiful podcast.
There was a lot of fun. I really,
really thank y'all for having me.
And I'm the first black
woman. Uh, no Tiffany,
she was the other one, right?
Sounds chronicles. Maybe.
Maybe it, oh shit. I broke history.
Have something to Rosa Parks,
Rosa Parks of this podcast.
I feel like we're maybe shut the
fuck up. Redman, I'm the first one.
I thought his name was
red bean and [inaudible].
Shit's
going to stick our thanks to our sponsor.
Thanks to honor.com go to o n n I t used
the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any
and all supplements.
Also, thanks to Naturebox,
go get your young Yum's on folks rich
and delicious and healthy and nutritious.
naturebox.com/rogan go there and enjoy it.
And if you don't get the Sriracha cashews,
you're a sucker MC,
naturebox.com/rogan
get 50% off your month.
First box and thanks also to stamps.com
go to stamps.com use the code word j.
R. E. N. Save yourself some money. Much
love my friends would be back soon.
Take care.
Drive safe.
Each of vegetables, big
kiss. Oh, August 1st
ace hotel in theater, downtown
La, Joey Diaz, Duncan Trussell.
And why come back?
See you soon.
Can I just tape you say happy
birthday? Yeah, sure. Yeah, definitely.